when you begin to create from the field
instead of from matter the only way you
can do that is you have to learn how to
take all of your attention off your body
and become a nobody take all of your
attention off all the people in your
life that you give so much of your
attention and energy to because you have
an emotion associated with them and get
beyond all the people in your life and
go from someone to a no one now if
you've worked your whole life being a
someone or if you've been working your
whole life thinking that you're your
body if you have to work a little harder
because that's your identity that's what
you're associated with and if this was
easy everybody would be doing it so then
you have to go get beyond all the things
in your life your cell phone your
computer your car and literally go from
something to nothing if I take all your
attention off the place you work the
place you live the place you need to be
the place you're sitting and go from
somewhere to Nowhere you got to stop
thinking about the predictable future
and the familiar past and go right into
the present moment and go from some time
to no time and if you do that properly
you become pure Consciousness that's how
you enter the field now we've done the
research on this we call it getting
beyond the self once you are pure
consciousness Europe taking all of your
attention off this three-dimensional
reality now where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
need motivation watch the top two and
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I quit on my business
partner I was making 300 bucks a month
and I didn't have the motivation to keep
going and the thing that got me through
was studying the stories of
entrepreneurs who've had massive success
and I hope that in sharing these stories
with you you find a motivation to keep
going and if I'm being honest I still
need the stories for myself today too so
today lesson from one of the best Joe
dispenza and my take on his top 50 rules
of success
enjoy
so if you've taken all of your attention
off of everything material
there's only one place you're going to
wind up and that is the in material
realm called the quantum field an
invisible field of energy that unifies
and connects everything material
so now when you're creating from the
field then you combine a clear intention
with an elevated emotion and you're
connected and you feel connected
the suggestion of an alternative way to
create is that when there's a
vibrational match between your energy
and some future reality
you actually no longer have to go
anywhere to get it you're actually the
vortex and you will collapse space and
time and draw the experience to you now
that to me is a lot more fun because the
experience is the unknown you can't
predict when it's going to happen or how
it's going to happen because if you can
predict it it's known so then you have
to lay down the very thing
you use your whole life to get what you
want
for something greater to occur now that
goes against
Generations Untold of conditioning and a
lifetime of habituation believing that
we're we're trapped in this material
world and yet I can I can say to you
without a doubt
then once you understand that formula
and once you know how to create that
kind of brain and heart coherence the
side effect of that
is a change in biology
neurologically chemically hormonally
genetically we've measured it we've seen
Gene regulation changes in four days
more brain coherence more hard coherence
your brain's working better your heart
is you're trusting your heart it's open
there's different chemicals that are
released oxytocin suppresses survival
centers resets the Baseline of a
person's trauma or shock
your immune system goes up
you you lengthen your telomeres we've
measured that too so you're changing the
future of your body you're extending
your life
that's evidence right so we we have the
evidence the know that it could happen
because we've measured it but the real
evidence
is watching the testimonial of someone
who says I had stage four cancer I was
told as a 41 year old woman that I
wouldn't live for more than two months
and I have no
evidence of cancer in my body at all or
someone that's a physician who has
Parkinson's disease that's tried
everything from the medical route and
has one transcendental moment and their
Tremors and their pain are gone then now
they're chewing food they're swallowing
uh they're blowing their nose they're
standing up on their own uh that's
energy affecting matter so we have
hundreds and hundreds of testimonials of
people that not only heal their body but
created pretty profoundly magical things
in their life
so you have evidence in the scientific
world you have evidence in the Practical
world and evidence
is the loudest voice right now the brain
is a record of the past it's an artifact
of everything we've learned and
experienced to this moment so most
people wake up in the morning and they
think about their problems and their
problems or memories that are etched in
their brain that are connected to
certain people and certain problems at
certain times in certain places and the
moment they start thinking of their
problems they're thinking in the past
the challenge is that every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
it and emotions really are a record of
the past so the moment you feel unhappy
the moment you feel suffering the moment
you feel
fear now your body's in the past so it's
the thought being the language of the
brain and the feeling being the language
or the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so many
people reaffirm their state of being
completely uh by the past and so it only
takes a thought and a feeling an image
and emotion a stimulus in response to
start the conditioning process so we
start to condition the brain and body
hardwire the brain condition the body
emotionally into the past the problem is
the body's so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating the
emotion and the emotion we're creating
by memory alone the body's believing us
living in the same past environment 24
hours a day seven days a week 365 days a
year so
and the person gets up and then they run
through the same routine as they always
do and uh in time their body moves into
a state of autopilot now their body is a
set of programs a habit that's dragging
them into the same future based on what
they did in the past and so to change
them also requires being greater than
the emotions that have been conditioned
into the body and the habituations that
have been conditioned into the body in
the predictable future so we have to
understand then that change requires not
only being created in the environment
but also being greater than our body
which is really for the most part been
conditioned to be the mind that's what a
habit is
so then
to change them to be greater than the
body to be greater than the environment
and be greater than time instead of
living in the familiar past which is the
known and the predictable future which
is the known you teach people how to
settle into the present moment and
that's the unknown and most people that
the unknown represents a very
threatening place and so when people
start to do meditation as an example and
their body starts looking for an arousal
or wants to get up and do things they
think they can't meditate but in fact if
they can settle their body back down
into the present moment and lower the
volume to that anger to that frustration
to the fear to the sadness
it's like training an animal now you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind and our research
shows there's a liberation of energy the
body starts expanding and relaxing into
the present moment instead of getting up
and checking your cell phone or doing
something and you notice that propensity
instead of responding to it and saying I
can't meditate you settle your body back
down into the present moment now you're
executing a will
that's greater than the program because
most people lose their free will to a
set of programs and it's the act of
doing this to be greater than the
conditions of our environment to be
greater than our body as the mind and
and to be greater than time
that all of a sudden causes the person
to start believing in themselves a
little bit more and that's when um
possibility starts to unfold let's say
you've had some pretty rough experiences
in your past
and those experiences cause you to feel
sad and unworthy and guilty
and judgmental
and you've gotten so used to feeling
guilty and unworthy and judgmental that
that's just feels normal to you
and then because you feel kind of
victimized
then you blame people and you complain
and you make excuses and you feel sorry
for yourself and that's your personality
and all of a sudden you say today
I'm not going to do that any longer
because that's the old self
and then you start off your day and it
goes really well for about two hours
and then all of a sudden the moment you
realize that you're no longer making the
same choices as the day before you are
going to feel uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar
it's going to be uncertain there's going
to be some unpredictability
and we now know that people would rather
hold on to their guilt and unworthiness
than to step into the unknown
because at least they can feel something
and so the moment you stop making the
same choices that you always make get
ready because it's going to be
uncomfortable and that's the moment
you're heading towards the new self
and we call it stepping into the river
of change
but now remember 95 percent of who you
are is your body as the mind
you know you've done something enough
times that your body does it better than
your brain
so you may actually complain
unconsciously because your body does it
all the time
and all of a sudden you say no
complaining
no more blaming no more feeling sorry
for myself no more talking about other
people I'm gonna stop
you know what happens don't you
the body starts sending signals to the
brain
the body's been conditioned that way
and all of a sudden you start hearing
thoughts in your head
that say why don't you start tomorrow
's a better day
this is too hard for me I can't change
something's wrong with me it's my
mother's fault it's my ex-husband's
fault it's my ex-wife's fault I'm this
way because of this event or the most
important one this doesn't feel right
and the moment you respond to that
thought is if it's true
that thought leads to the same Choice
which leads to the same behavior that
creates the same experience that
produces the same emotion and the person
says this feels right
that feels familiar
going from the old self to the new self
stepping into that void stepping into
that uncertainty is the biological the
neurological the chemical the hormonal
genetic death of the old self
and people will say to us well in that
unknown I can't predict my life or my
future
and we always say the same thing to them
the best way to predict your future is
to create it not from the known but from
the unknown
and when you and I get comfortable in
the place of the unknown that's where
the magic happens and it never happens
in the known if you have a very brain
driven person like myself
and in some parts I disconnected from my
emotions just to protect me in regular
life
and it's a challenge for me to reconnect
to my old emotions that I already had in
circumstances that would help
um do you have any advice
yeah well uh God I have a lot of advice
around that because
um
70 of the time that people in their
waking lives
they live in a very protective State
they live in a state of stress or in a
state of survival in fact it's such a
program that we don't know that we're
doing this we're always
expanding the environment to determine
if it's safe or not and if something
appears out of the predictable or
unknown it alerts us and we move into a
state of arousal and we begin to turn on
the very systems that begin to say
danger threat possible scenario that's
not safe
and when that happens we literally begin
to anticipate an outcome
and when we do that we're always
preparing for what could go wrong
and we begin to create the emotions
ahead of the experience of what happens
if it goes wrong whether it's fear
anxiety worry sadness pain when we do
that unconsciously that's what a program
is
and that becomes the habit
so if you're living in a world where men
have to provide and show a certain
amount of success and be competitive
then you're not going to open your heart
it's not a time to do that it's a time
to survive and thrive in an environment
and yet
um in our work I see men that if they
practice
yeah opening their hearts and it's just
being a child again being a boy again
being curious being wondering being free
being allowing yourself to let go also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there we're all faced with uh
great challenges brilliantly disguised
as impossible situations and there's
always a door there is always a door
and so
your personality creates your personal
reality it's that simple and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this show has created the present
personal reality called their life which
means if you're going to change
something in your personal reality
in your life you got to change your
personality you have to change nothing
changes
until you change that's the bottom line
you change but you the thought of
changing my personality seems so like
but I like who I am kinda but I'm also
cranky I'm also annoyed so like who is
that person underneath
all of these ailments I guess all of
these but it's a weird thing to say you
change your personality
well look I mean there's many things
that I love about my personality just
like you do I'm gonna take that with me
but there are things if I'm going to be
defined by a vision of the future
they're things that can't come because
the moment you say I want to have a
mystical experience where I transcend
this three-dimensional world and and you
want to have a really profound moment a
transcendental moment you start showing
up for that and it doesn't happen right
away then one you're gonna start
disbelieving you start but stop
believing yourself though so the moment
we're defined by a vision of the future
that's bigger than us that vision of the
future is not the vision of the past and
when we do that we take away we take
with us our discipline we take our
concentration we take our
presence we take our passion we take our
strengths with us all those things you
take but the things that are standing in
the way are those old beliefs are things
that stand in a way that that that that
stop you from connecting to it those are
the things you come up against and and
it's not that it's not the mystical
experience of the transcendental
experience it's who you become it's not
your wealth it's not your health it's
who you become it's not your freedom
it's who you become in the process and
it's the overcoming process that we
overcome that we overcome that we
overcome that we overcome till we
finally become and so many great people
in history you know even wealthy people
people always want to be wealthy but if
you study wealthy people that really did
it they failed miserably thousands of
times until they figured it out and so
you keep showing up for yourself enough
times
You're Gonna Change you're going to
change you're going to be thinking
differently you're going to be acting
differently you're going to be feeling
differently and that's when the universe
starts to conspire in ways that we just
never even thought about that's that's
that's the beauty behind creation when a
person begins to slow their brain waves
down they have to go when you're in
stress when you're in survival you
narrow your focus on a cause that's
called a what's called a convergent
Focus so now you're blessing the energy
centers of the body they're under the
control of the autonomic nervous system
and when the autonomic nervous system
moves out of balance the brain moves out
of balance right we narrow our focus on
the cause and it causes each one of
these different energy centers
to move into incoherence as well and
those little little individual brains
start moving into incoherence and send
an incoherent message to the cells and
tissues and organs hormones then become
down regulated and the body starts
moving out of balance
so when we bless the energy centers
where we reprogram these energy centers
two things has to happen
they have to be able to slow their brain
waves down they have to get out of that
high beta State and the way we do it is
to go from a narrow Focus to a broad
focus when you open your focus when you
open your awareness that's what creates
coherence in the brain because you're
going against that habit
putting your attention on matter
so there's a convergent Focus which is
focusing on matter and then there's a
Divergent Focus which is focusing on
energy well reality is both particle and
wave matter and energy so if a person
can slow their brain waves down from
beta brain waves to Alpha brain waves
now they're starting to fall out of
their thinking brain right into the home
of the autonomic nervous system okay the
person can't change their brain waves
it'll never work because they're in
their neocortex in their thinking mind
right so that's one thing that has to
happen the second thing that has to
happen is that they have to practice
both a convergent focus and a Divergent
Focus now by the convergent you're
focusing on let's say I'm going to focus
on this energy center right and then you
move your focus to another energy well
first you first you focus on that energy
center that's particle and then you
focus on the space around it that's wave
and so when you open your awareness and
you're able to do that and you're in
your autonomic nervous system you can
put an intention there which will create
more balance and estrogen more balance
and your your sexual organs you move to
your second Center you put your
attention there that's your where you
place your attention is where you place
your energy so now you're beginning to
Direct Energy yeah into that Center but
now you become aware of the space around
it why to create coherence and that
little brain send the coherent message
to the cells and tissues go to your
third center right in the pit of your
gut well there's a huge Celiac plexus
there solar plexus a lot of connections
in there so now put your big one that's
a big oh it's getting a lot of signs
there yeah here and here part and solar
plexus yeah that's those are big ones
and you tune into that energy then you
put your attention in your heart it has
its own individual brain yeah and when
you make energy here when energy finally
arrives here guess where it goes
automatically straight up we've measured
it so now once you start opening your
heart you've got more energy in your
heart you get more energy in your brain
got it show it on time just go straight
to the heart that's why we do it that's
exactly why we that's why we open the
heart so it creates a field and it
begins to drive energy of the brain so
now that energy is going to cause the
person
to have a different Consciousness a
different thought pattern right and now
they're going to be thinking possibility
because in survival the first three ones
are all about survival yeah it's really
not a creative process of creating from
mind it's more about a more primitive
you know
um
humanistic part of us you know animal
part of us so then there's the thyroid
plexus the pineal gland the pituitary
gland so we've seen when people create
coherence in each one of these energy
centers and they do it properly they
know how to change their brain waves
they get into the operating system they
can Master convergent and Divergent
Focus they're no longer living just this
way they've practiced opening their
awareness and focus on energy becoming
conscious of it and as these brains
become more coherent and they start
producing different signals to hormones
and chemicals and into different glands
in the body that's what's being
upregulated to make different different
Expressions would you say it's smart to
focus on one goal I mean if you're sick
obviously it's it's smart to focus on
only getting healthy but if you have a
regular life and you say you know I
would like to have the classical stuff
for More Money More wealth more love
more joy would you say in those
meditations it's smart to focus on
different goals or should it rather be
the Big Goal like a big Vision I have
for my life that all the steps on the
way are just
marks I will pass at one point well
let's answer that on two levels too
because people come to our workshops for
all different reasons some people come
because they're sick some people come
because they want more money some people
want more a new job a new opportunity a
new career a new relationship some
people want the mystical the people come
for all kinds of reasons to me I don't
care
what I care about is that they latch on
to a vision
and they learn how to create whatever
drives them to that elegant moment where
they're so present and so passionate
about what they want and they have a
clear intention a Clear Vision a
coherent brain
and they have an elevated emotion
combined with it that they create hard
coherence and now they're broadcasting a
whole new energy into the field and
whatever we broadcast into the field
is our experiment with Destiny
so I want people
to know the how because we have plenty
of people that have made millions and
millions of dollars that were living in
the back seat of our car or filed
bankruptcy we have plenty people that
were staged for cancer serious health
conditions that are healed but really
people think they come for those reasons
but we come for wholeness that's why we
come that when we feel so whole and so
happy with ourselves so connected to
something greater
if you feel wholeness
it's impossible for you to want
how can you want when you're whole when
you're whole you feel like you have
everything
so
I want people
to reach that point where
they feel so whole
that they no longer want and that's when
the magic happens teaching them that
allows them to understand that when they
come back to their senses they open
their eyes
they're not looking
for the experience they feel like it's
already happened and if you feel like
it's already happened why would you be
looking for it then
if your body is conditioned emotionally
into that future
you're not separate from the energy of
your future you're connected from it to
it but the moment you get in traffic and
you start getting angry you get on the
line at the bank and you start getting
impatient or you're sitting in a staff
meeting you start judging A co-worker
you just disconnected from the energy of
the future and now you're back to the
energy of your past and you've done
nothing wrong
you just lost your connection to the
Future now now the importance of that is
to notice that you're disconnected and
if you say to me well that person made
me feel this way and think this way I'd
say oh my gosh you're back to the
unconscious program of being a victim in
your life the victim is saying that
someone or something is controlling how
I think and feel
a person who's producing outcomes in
their life all of a sudden they say wow
the way I'm thinking and feeling is
creating outcomes in my life
now I'm a creator of my life and now I
believe less and I'm a victim of my life
I want to show you what it looks like
when you learn something new you have a
hundred billion neurons in your brain
a hundred billion neurons
the number of connections you have in
one neuron is between ten thousand and
forty thousand connections if you took a
hundred thou hundred billion sheets of
paper and you stack them on top of each
other it would be 5 000 Miles High
that's the distance from Los Angeles to
London
if you took a scoop of gray matter the
size of a grain of sand you would have a
hundred thousand neurons in it with over
a billion connections now
I'll stop right after this slide
learning is making new synaptic
connections every time you learn
something new this is what's happening
in your brain geniuses
if you learned one bit of information
today
your brain did this
boom that's learning
physical evidence as a result of your
interaction in the environment
every time you learn something in your
brain there's a physical change that
takes place and learning is making new
connections
are you with me
this is how fast it happens too
that's learning if you learn anything
this week you've made a footprint if
learning is making new synaptic
connections
then if you keep firing the same
thoughts over and over again you're
going to wire them in your brain
so then if learning is making new
synaptic connections then remembering is
maintaining them
and all of a sudden they develop a
long-term relationship and just like any
relationship the more you communicate
the more they connect and neurons are
exactly the same way
now as you begin to learn information
neurons tend to assemble themselves into
networks or what's called neural
networks and neural networks are just
gangs of neurons that have fired and
wired together to form a community of
neurosynaptic connections that's related
to a thought a skill a habit a behavior
a concept
and neural networks are automatic
programs you have a neural network to
brush your teeth to put on makeup to
speak a language to walk
all of a sudden those neurons then form
a hardware circuitry but if you keep
repeating it the hardware becomes a
software program and it becomes
automatic people think that they want
certain things because they're
experiencing lack
and and so they have to go about
becoming
the very person so then if we reframe it
and you say oh I really want to be
wealthy I want all my needs met and I'll
say really why you want to be wealthy
and they'll say because I want freedom
I'd say okay let's focus on freedom
so now the person understands the
sponsoring thought or the emotion why
would you wait for your wealth to feel
free that's the Newtonian model of
reality of cause and effect waiting for
someone or something out there to take
away this emptiness or lack and what if
I'm feeling this emotion this emotion is
influencing certain thoughts and how I
think and feel creates my life if I'm
living in lack I'm not going to create
anything new
but if I say to you hey when you become
that person
once you become it then your your
reality is going to reorganize itself
instead of living by cause and effect
let's teach you how to cause an effect
so then the person then is no longer
interested in getting something in their
environment when they realize it's about
who they become
and all of a sudden now the emphasis or
the interest is in becoming that person
and we have a week with those people and
I want them to walk as it sit as it
stand as lay down I said I want them to
get in the habit of walking from their
room to the ballroom it's become the new
habit that's why when we do our work
you're we're doing sitting meditations
we're doing standing and walking
meditations we're doing lying down
meditations I want it to become a new
habit I want them to become that person
one of my biggest problems is that I
tend to react quickly to negative
situations
how how can I cope with anger do you
have any suggestions or advice
yeah I'll tell you the first thing
it's not that you react we all react
the question is how long are you going
to react that's the question so
we found out that when people react
emotionally with anger with antagonism
uh there's an arousal that takes place
because you're turning on the
sympathetic nervous system and the
sympathetic nervous systems the
Primitive system saying Alex whatever
that whatever that is is a threat to you
and if there's a threat a good way to
deal with a threat is to get aggressive
that's primitive it's animal it's very
animal some people will say oh my God
there's my ex and instead of getting
angry they run
they they they they flee they're in fear
they're like the fear is I'm better just
getting away so they they Their Fear
causes them to run uh uh so uh when
people feel fear when they feel anger
when they feel pain those are the
primary stimulators that switch on that
sympathetic nervous system and they used
to say
that it's automatic like it's automatic
it happens automatically that's part of
the autonomic nervous system and you
really don't have any control of it
turns out that's absolutely not the
truth so first thing
is learning how to shorten your response
to the emotional reaction so if you have
an event that happens to your life in in
your life and I say
Alex why are you so mad today and you
say oh it's because of this situation
and this person this has happened this
way and I would say oh my gosh all right
do you mean
that that person or that circumstance is
controlling the way you feel and the way
you think
now anything that's controlling the way
we feel in the way we think makes us
victims
whatever that is now that's okay but if
you keep that emotional reaction going
on
for hours or days and I say to you Alex
it's five days what's up and you say to
me I'm I'm upset from something that
happened to me five days ago I'd say you
have a mood you're in a mood now some
people
keep that same emotional reaction going
on
for weeks or months and then I would say
well Alex has a angry temperament it
becomes a temperament
if we keep it going for now this is true
people keep this going for years on end
if it goes on for years now it's a
personality trait so here's the weird
part about it you ask that person who's
been angry for years why they're angry
and they'll recall an event from 10
years ago or a series of events from 10
years ago yeah
and the research on the memory says that
50 of that story isn't even the truth
that they can't even remember the truth
they embellish the story and make it
sound worse than it really was to excuse
themselves from changing now
what we tell people is
forget the event
doesn't matter the details of the event
doesn't what matters
is learning how to overcome the emotion
so when you're sitting in a meditation
and all of a sudden out of nowhere your
body starts getting aroused and it
starts getting frustrated and it starts
getting angry and people say I'm doing
my meditation wrong you know what I say
to them no no no no you're doing it
right because that has to come up so
then
so when the anger and the frustration
comes up and a person's in a meditation
they have one of two choices to quit
which is what they've always done
but if you're sitting with 1500 people
and no one else is quitting you're not
going to quit
and if I teach you how to lower the
volume to that emotion and I teach you a
way to change that while the brain is
organized to reflect everything you know
in your life your brain is a record of
your environment so it begs the question
does the environment control your
thinking
or does your thinking control the
environment so if you wake up every
morning and you do the same things and
you go to the same places and you see
the same people and you react in the
same way and you perform the same
behaviors
it really is the external environment
that's turning on different circuits in
your brain causing you to think equal to
everything that you know
and as long as you keep thinking equal
to everything you know that's familiar
and the same according to the quantum
model you creating more of the same to
change then is the thing greater than
our environment the think greater than
the conditions in our world the hardest
part about change is not making the same
Choice as you did the day before
when you decide to make a different
Choice whether it's to change something
that you eat or to exercise or to no
longer react to certain people or
conditions in your life remember you're
going to feel uncomfortable now that's
not a bad thing that's actually a good
thing that means you're in the unknown
and when you step into the unknown
you're going through dramatic changes in
your own personal biology
when you're in that place of uncertainty
that place of unpredictability that void
that unknown ask yourself what thoughts
do you want to believe in and fire and
wire in your brain what behaviors would
you like to demonstrate that's equal to
a vision of the future close your eyes
and rehearse them review every step no
different than an athlete beginning to
rehearse what they're about to do the
act of rehearsing it begins to prime
your brain to prepare you for that
behavior in your future and then finally
can you teach your body emotionally what
that future is going to feel like before
it happens and when you begin to fall
into the present moment and marry those
intentions with an elevated emotion your
body is believing it's living in that
future reality in the present moment and
you're changing your biology from living
in your past present reality to living
in your future present reality in your
job then is to be able to maintain that
modified State of Mind and Body your
entire day and if you can get ready
because something unusual is going to
happen in your life it's the law we may
not be able to control everything in our
outer world but we certainly can control
our inner world and so it's not so
important to not react I mean everybody
reacts I react the question is how long
are you going to react
so if you keep an emotional reaction
going on for an extended period of time
you're memorizing that emotion and your
body is the unconscious mind is
believing it's living in the same past
experience 24 hours a day seven days a
week 365 days a year the body doesn't
know the difference between the real
experience that produces the emotion and
emotion that we create by thought alone
so then the emotion then reaffirms the
state and then people start to use the
problems and the conditions in their
life to keep that emotion going and I
would call that an addiction so we
become addicted to the very life we
don't even like
so
it's important then for people to
realize then when you have that moment
where you have crisis or something
breaks down that you do have control
over it and it's a formula and it's a
skill and our research shows that you
can teach people how to do that and so
then when you're living by some emotion
there'll always be a gap between the way
things appear and the way things really
are emotions alter our perception and if
you act during that time you'll always
say the same thing I should have never
said that I should have never done that
I should never thought that I should
have never sent that email so then
shortening your emotional reactions
is a level of intelligence then that
causes you then to recalibrate because
most people don't think they have
control over that they'll say that
person did it to me that circumstance is
the reason I am this way then I would
say if something in your outer
environment
is controlling your thoughts and
feelings then you're a victim to your
environment and yet
how you think and feel creates your
outer world so if you're thinking and
feeling equal to everything that's known
in your present personal reality you
keep creating more of the same so to
change then is to think and feel greater
than the conditions in your environment
and to be able to do that to such a
degree then you're no longer reacting to
the same people in the same way and that
takes an effort it's and it's not easy
in the beginning but once you start
practicing
uh you get better at it and just like
anything else you start to move through
your life with more coherence and you're
less likely to knee-jerk and if you're
less likely to knee jerk then you're not
in an unconscious program I think one of
the most important things when we lose
sight of our vision is to make time for
ourselves and I think that when you
invest in yourself you invest in your
future
disconnecting from people in your life
and places that you have to go and
things that you do or things that you
own long enough to begin to reignite a
vision of how you see yourself or how
you see your future and begin to
emotionally Embrace that future and
change your state of being allows us to
see a whole new landscape if you've lost
sight of your vision take a moment and
remember that vision and begin to
emotionally embrace it and from that
state of being start to think about the
things you want to do the choices you
want to mix write them down review the
behaviors that you have to demonstrate
your goals and experiences and how it's
going to feel when you do that enough
times you're changing your brain
neurologically and you're changing your
body genetically write down the
unconscious thoughts that you have to
stay conscious of become aware of the
choices that you no longer need to make
review the behaviors and habits you have
to change about yourself and become so
conscious of them that you won't go
unconscious at all during your day
remember the experiences in your
environment that you need to stay away
from whether it's a person or a thing
just for a period of time
so that you can keep that Vision alive
and most importantly review those
emotions that keep you connected to the
past and become so conscious of them and
name them when you feel that feeling
that if it's guilt or sadness or pain
the moment you start feeling it and you
become conscious of it that's when you
can begin to change and if you keep
doing this over and over again the
unlearning and the relearning the
breaking the habit of the old self and
Reinventing a new self is going to cause
you to arrive at a whole new future and
when you do this could become your new
habit you can't go to the Future holding
on to the biology of your past decide
what thoughts you can bring to your
future write them down thoughts like I
can't it's too hard I'll never change
I'll start tomorrow what's wrong with me
it's someone else's fault
decide on what behaviors or actions or
unconscious habits you have to change
how do you talk do you complain do you
blame do you make excuses do you feel
sorry for yourself it just becomes so
conscious of those behaviors that you'll
never go unconscious again and lastly
you have to decide what emotions no
longer belong in your future that means
if you want to be wealthy you can take
lack if you want to be healthy you can't
take insecurity or fear you got to begin
to condition your body to a new mind if
you do this
every single day your personality
creates your personal reality and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel change any
one of those things and you change your
life and begin to measure the effects of
you it cause give it a shot your
personality creates your personal
reality and your personality is made up
of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this little video has created the
present personal reality called your
life
which means then if you wanted to create
a new personal reality a new life you
would have to change your personality
that means you'd have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and change it it means you'd have to
become aware of your unconscious habits
and behaviors and modify them
and you'd have to look at certain
emotions that keep you connected to
experiences in the past and decide do
these emotions belong in your future
the beauty behind this is is that when
you begin to change how you think how
you act and how you feel you should
begin to see changes in your life and I
recommend that you try it out the
majority of our thoughts and feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering or shame or unworthiness or
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion and stress is a lot of
energy that that we're drawing from our
very vital life force yes a resource of
light and information and we're turning
it into chemistry and we're literally
robbing the body's energy right so so
then living like that for the short term
is okay because the body can move back
to homeostasis and then restore itself
but
when we're overdoing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so again you can
eat all the right food you can do all
the right things but if you're living in
anxiety and fear and you're viewing your
world from the worst case scenario that
could possibly happen because that's
what you do in survival there's no
energy for growth and repair there's no
energy for healing so the majority of
our thoughts are signaling certain
circuits in the brain that signal
another part of the brain the limit
brain to make what's called a
neuropeptide neuropeptides are chemical
Messengers that signal hormonal centers
so now you're taking thought and you're
storing it as energy in these energy
centers and and if you're living in
survival why would you open your heart I
mean it's just not a time to open your
heart I mean if you're getting chased by
T-Rex it's not a time to meditate it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
connect it's not a time to communicate
it's not a time to sit down and go
within it's not a time to be vulnerable
it's time to run fighter hide to change
is to be greater than your environment
that means be greater than the
conditions in your life to be greater
than the circumstances in your world in
every great person in history knew this
that means you have to be defined by a
vision in the future instead of the
memories of the past to change means be
greater than your body those unconscious
habits and behaviors and choices that
you've made over and over again so many
times that the body becomes the Mind
emotions that are connected to past
experiences keep you anchored
emotionally to the past and if those
emotions are driving your thoughts and
those thoughts are creating the same
emotions then your body has become the
mind which means that in order for you
to change you're going to have to get
greater than those emotional reactions
habits and hardwired attitudes that keep
you running unconscious programs and to
change then is to be greater than time
if you're waking up every single day and
making the same choices and
demonstrating the same behaviors and
creating the same experiences and you do
that over and over again it makes sense
that your past is going to look a lot
like your future and your future will be
more of your past finding The Sweet Spot
of the generous present moment existing
in that place where you're no longer
trying to predict the future based on
the past means you're in the unknown and
when you're in that place called The
Eternal present moment that's where all
possibilities exist give it a try think
about this
if you spend the majority of your day
focusing on matter
focusing on everything in this
three-dimensional world that's made of
material things it begs the question how
much of your time and your attention do
you put on that unified field that
invisible field of information that
exists beyond space and time
and just like when you're unaware of
your nose it doesn't exist and the
moment you become aware of it it exists
the quantum field is exactly the same
way if you put very little attention on
it in your waking day then it doesn't
exist for you but the moment you begin
to become aware of it the moment you
begin to pay attention to it the moment
you begin to stay present with it and to
experience it moment after moment and
where you place your attention as you
learned is where you place your energy
and where you place your attention
causes things to expand the moment you
begin to experience it not with your
senses you experience this
three-dimensional reality with your
senses but you experience it with your
Consciousness and with your awareness
the moment you become pure Consciousness
is the moment you make contact with that
unified field and so we now know
the techniques and the tools to get
people Beyond themselves and in fact we
know that after thousands and thousands
and thousands of brain scans that you're
at your absolute best when you get
Beyond yourself when you take your
attention off your body
when you take your attention off your
identity that's connected to people in
your life the things you own objects you
own places you have to go in time itself
the moment you become nobody no one no
thing no where in no time that is the
moment you become pure Consciousness and
that's the moment you begin to connect
to that field of possibilities called
the unified field or the quantum field
and that field in this invisible field
of information that exists Beyond this
space and time and independent of the
color of your skin your gender your diet
your sexual preference independent of
your profession your class
independent of all those things that
create separation
that every human being has access to it
I always tell my advancing students you
know when you're changing is when you
stop talking about it
because when you are truly changing you
can't go to church and shake hands and
say peace be with you and then get in
your car and cut everybody off on the
way out of the parking lot you can't say
I don't like the war in Iraq and be
arguing with your next door neighbor or
your co-worker you have to be the living
example of everything you want to see in
the world in terms of change if you
don't like greed start giving
you know you have to demonstrate and
when you do you give people permission
to do the same because they're going to
observe you doing exactly what they're
afraid to do but they know it's the
right thing to do so the way we
transform the world as we transform
ourselves
the way you transform a culture is you
transform an individual an individual by
individual when we stop looking outside
of us and we say that world is a
reflection of some aspect of me if
everybody in the world did that
simultaneously imagine how the world
would change and it's not enough to just
focus on peace yeah there's been great
studies that have shown that when a
community of people focus on peace that
the crime rate's drop but when they
leave and the research is over the crime
rates return back to the ceiling value
it's not enough to just think you got to
demonstrate it you've got to show it in
all areas of your life and when you
demonstrate it now it becomes an example
for people to follow your personality
creates your personal reality
that's it
and your personality is made up of how
you think
how you act
and how you feel
so the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life
so if you believe what I just said then
in order for you to create a new
personal reality a new life you're gonna
have to change your personality in other
words nothing changes in your life until
you change that's the way it is so it
turns out the 90 of the thoughts that we
think on a daily basis are the same
thoughts as the day before
same thoughts lead to the same choices
same choices lead to the same behaviors
same behaviors create the same
experiences the same experiences produce
the same feelings and the same emotions
and those same feelings and emotions
begin to influence our very same
thoughts and our biology
our neural circuitry our neural
chemistry are hormones are gene
expression our immune system
all stay the same because we're staying
the same so then there's a principle in
Neuroscience that says that nerve cells
that fire together wire together you
keep thinking the same thoughts they
keep making the same choices you keep
doing the same things you keep creating
the same experiences that stamp the same
networks of neurons into the same exact
patterns all for the reaffirming of the
same feeling and you do that for 10
years on end
the firing and wiring of those
circuitries begins to hardwire the brain
into a very finite signature that box in
the brain that's created is the same
level of mind and if you keep doing that
it becomes automatic
and turns out that 95 of Who We Are by
the time we're in the middle of our life
is a set of memorized behaviors
automatic emotional reactions constant
habits hardwired attitudes beliefs
perceptions
that have happened just because we've
we've just fired and wired it the same
way so there's a good possibility then
in order for us to change we better
start thinking about what we've been
thinking about and changing we have to
become conscious of our unconscious
habits and behaviors and modify them
we've got to look at these feelings that
we feel every single day instead of just
thinking it's a feeling say what is this
is this guilt is this sadness is this
unhappiness is this pain is it
frustration is it resentment what is the
feeling that I'm living by the majority
of my day now
that's lighting a match in a dark place
and Neuroscience is called metacognition
the word meditation means to become
familiar with that's what it means
so the more familiar with you are I
can't with I can't it's too hard I'm
never going to change it's my ex's fault
it's my boss's fault it's my country's
fault it's the government it's the
weather it's my pain whatever that
thought is that you accept believe and
surrender to on a daily basis that's
automatic
you have to become so conscious of that
unconscious thought
that it doesn't slip by your awareness
unnoticed you got to catch yourself
saying I'm tired I'm unhappy at someone
else's fault do you complain do you
blame do you make excuses do you feel
sorry for yourself that that personality
has to change in order to create a new
life so then you have to become so aware
of your unconscious habits that you
don't go unconscious to them in your
waking day then you got to sit in the
fire of those emotions
and you gotta watch those emotions come
up and you have to sit with them and
know that there's something on the other
side of them now this is where most
people get up and say I can't meditate
or I'm going to call up my friend or I'm
gonna get on social media and make a
post I'm gonna turn on the football game
I'm gonna get distracted because I need
something out there to make this go away
and what we're saying is we're not
relying on anything out there that's the
that's the hypnosis that's the
conditioning we want you to just become
so familiar with that feeling that you
catch yourself in your waking day the
moment you start
feeling sad and your energy drops ah you
catch yourself so
there's an unlearning process
or breaking the habit of being the old
self process that requires
a lot of attention
a lot of awareness and it takes energy
you've got to stay conscious if you
think about great leaders in history
that change the course of many different
cultures
what they did that was so important is
they had a vision of that future
and they were able to have other people
come out of their resting emotional
state uh and begin to see that Vision
that they were seeing and move them into
an elevated emotional state and when
they changed their energy those people
could share that same vision well if you
combine a clear intention in an elevated
emotion those two ingredients change
people's state of being now the person
is just moved biologically from living
in the past to living in a new future in
the present moment and that's what
caused millions of people to begin to
make different choices to behave
differently to do different things and
if you get enough people doing that
because of mirror neurons everybody's
observing everybody do it and you create
a collective Consciousness and great
leaders have the ability to
based on core principles whether it's
Justice or Freedom or equality to have
people see that same vision and then
move them out of their resting state
into an elevated emotion and then when
they do that properly those people can
see that Vision if you can't change a
person's energy
they'll never see that Vision because
they'll be viewing the future through
the lens of the past the emotions of the
past and so great leaders have the
ability to to have people begin to see
the same vision if your personality is
made up of how you think how you act and
how you feel and it is yes or no
and you stop thinking the same way and
nerve cells that no longer fire together
no longer wire together every place
where one neuron connects with another
neuron is called the memory
so as you begin to unfire and unwire you
prune the very circuits in your brain
that are connected to the old self and
the memory
of the old self begins to mutate begins
to change so then you would say where
is that memory stored and it's stored in
the soul now
as wisdom because you're no longer that
person yes or no
and if you could no longer behave the
same way in nerve cells that no longer
fire together no longer wire together
and pruning is part of biology you don't
use it you lose it
then your memory of the old self would
begin to change and that is a biological
death in the beginning that is
uncomfortable for a lot of people
if you're no longer feeling the same
emotions that keep you connected to the
past and you keep inhibiting that
process the body will be craving the
chemicals in the beginning because it's
been conditioned that way it's been it's
been addicted it's the mind and it's
anticipating events and the emotions
from those events and you're putting the
brakes on
and that's uncomfortable
and you got to stay conscious and it
takes an enormous amount of energy and
you're no longer signaling the same
genes and producing the same hormones
and your body is no longer being
influenced by your mind in the same way
and sometimes the mind is the biggest
enemy to the body
and you're inhibiting that process
and the body which has become the Mind
wants its way
and it's uncomfortable to change and you
got to be able to be greater than that
to truly change and everybody that's
changed has come up against that feeling
and they almost make the same choice and
they don't and they're so glad that they
didn't
and it takes an enormous amount of
energy and awareness to do that so as
the old self
deconstructs because you have the free
will to decide who you want to be on a
moment-to-moment basis and if your life
isn't changing and you want to change
your life you got to change and now you
are playing the game and you are now
saying this personality
this person that I've become I'm in the
habit of being it and I want to become
somebody else
and the more you learn about love the
more you learn about life the more you
learn about possibility and potential
the more you become aware of it there
are more possibilities and knowledge is
the thing that gives us that
and so the old self
is a memory like another lifetime like
you can remember it but you're no longer
interested in it any longer because it
no longer defines you
how many people understand what I'm
talking about so then the biological
death of the old self is crossing a
river of change and you got to stay with
it long enough to become somebody else
and you think it's about wealth it's you
think it's about health it's about who
you become
the people who become somebody else they
they see dramatic changes in their
health and in their lives
and and they can't find the words to be
able to explain it
but it's practical though if you truly
want to change your life you have to
change yourself you would have to be
conscious of your thoughts and aware of
your actions and and familiar with those
emotions and you would never fall from
grace and if you did you would stop and
self-correct if you truly were
interested in evolution and if you said
to me it's I lost it because of that
person
I'd say that you're back to the
unconscious program of allowing your
environment to control how you feel and
think you got two choices stay there
for another six hours or pause and
change your energy change your energy
and get back to the emotions of your
future and the feelings of your future
it's a much better place to be
reason this with me
you could have a great meditation and
condition your body just like you did
into the future
you come back to your senses and you
return back to the same old self romance
in the past again
you're going to weigh that one 50 minute
one hour meditation against the rest of
the day back to you
you got to start practicing we have to
start doing it with our eyes open and
the font of who we want to become should
produce the feeling of it
instantaneously in other words the
thought of your future should produce
the feeling that it already happened
instead of the feeling of lack because
it hasn't happened
how many people understand that and the
people who do this well they condition
their body into the future and they say
I don't know how it happened it's like
my body was led right to the event and
your body is going to follow your mind
to an unknown just like it follows your
mind to the toilet every morning but
instead of it being known it's going to
be the unknown
that's where your attention and your
energy has been
I'm telling you it doesn't matter what
you believe in doesn't matter the color
your skin what you eat I don't care it
doesn't matter I've seen it in all ways
so then the thought of our future if
we're doing this properly should produce
the feeling that it already happened
if the thought of your future produces
the lack that it hasn't happened you're
still in your past and nothing is going
to change
and it would make sense then that you
would want to get that heart open on a
regular basis so that you can feel the
emotions of your future before it
happens I'm telling you there's a lot of
biology that changes in you
can you do it enough times you become
that person
the thought of it then produces the
feeling that it's already happened
that's how you know you're getting close
independent of what's going on in your
life
that's when you're mastering yourself
and mastering your life I have sat in
meditations and out of nowhere I had the
most icky
so familiar but so foreign feeling moved
through me that it was I don't know I
never saw it coming I didn't know what
it was
and all I did was instead of run and
turn on my cell phone or lay down or
quit I was curious if there was
something on the other side of it
so if I stay present with it and felt it
it was an energy and that energy is a
frequency and that frequency carries
information or the emotion has a memory
however you want to say it
and so you have to pass through the
valley of the shadow of Darkness many
times to find the light and I have sat
with my body
curious to wonder if there's anything on
the other side of this emotion and if I
stayed present with it and felt it it
would turn into something else in time
and so then
think about it you know we have
different Sensations that our body
experiences you may feel like a
tightening in your throat and your
respiratory rate going up and kind of
flush
and your heart of uh fluttering and you
may be feeling
anxious but all of those Sensations that
the body is recording your
interpretation of it is anxiety or being
anxious so the sensations then the human
Sensations as information we call it an
emotions the moment we name it it's
anxiety but those Sensations that come
up for the body is information so people
then sitting in the presence of that
information
and allowing you to experience it fully
will cause you to move through it now
for me
I'm all about this
if it's familiar if it's a familiar
feeling more than likely I'm back in
some unconscious program
because the emotion is driving certain
behaviors certain habits certain
thoughts now that doesn't mean that
people can't go through grieving
processes but I do believe that that
process for some people becomes a way
for them to get attention
and to get things in their life that
they need and they use it in a way that
becomes part of their identity and they
do that unconsciously
and so for me I would say then what
greater piece of knowledge could I learn
about grief or about myself that I would
want to apply to evolve my experience of
it and see if there's something on the
other side of it so
we look for those answers then and we
build a model
for example people grieve a lot for for
people that die and I totally get it but
if you had a greater understanding of
death
you may not have such a grief for that
long because you would say my goodness
if I truly love this person if you pass
this plane and you saw someone you loved
walking around suffering what would you
say to them after a period of time
hey if you love me live your life come
on I'm going on go enjoy so I always
look what is my limited belief about
about something and could I learn to to
expand my awareness of what's possible
so if you feel the grief stay present
with it
and see by staying present with it if
there's something on the other side sit
with it long enough I I have I've had so
many dark nights I've sat with it until
it turned into something else I just I
just was curious I didn't want anything
out there to do it
I wanted to do it and when it matters
the most is when it's the hardest that's
what I know what's emerging in the world
now because of information
is teaching people that there are other
possibilities that they were unconscious
to and you don't need an authority any
longer you don't need a priest you don't
need a governor you don't need a teacher
you don't need a doctor to gain
information any longer information is
available but the question is
what will you do with it so if you give
people sound scientific information and
science is the language of mysticism and
you combine quantum physics with
neuroscience and neuroendocrinology and
psychon or immunology and epigenetics
and electromagnetism and make it simple
and don't talk about tradition or
religion or culture that's going to
divide it on the audience but bring the
model of Science in
a person can reason and understand what
they're doing with that information
and why they're doing it then the side
effect of how they're doing it is going
to get easier and now the application
becomes essential so what we're seeing
is this the emergent Consciousness where
people are taking their power back
and not relying on anyone or anything
for their own personal change or
transformation and I think that when you
get enough people doing it emergence in
biology is a group of birds all moving
in the same direction of school of fish
all moving the appearance is a larger
organism they're behaving in the exact
same way there's no leader when you
study that in biology everybody's
leading so how are we going to change
the world it's not one person not one
Consciousness it's a collective
Consciousness and the research says that
Collective networks of observers
determine reality get enough people
believing in possibility sooner or later
someone's going to run into that
experience and you need one once you
know it's possible then other people
will start doing it as well just like
the four minute mile so
so in the world right now I think we're
seeing it breaking down
of so many conventions where whether
it's religion or medicine or the
environment there's journalism
everything's falling apart right now
because it can't sustain itself because
no organisms in nature live in this kind
of abusive competition we organisms
survive in cooperation and connection
and communion
keep people in fear
keep them angry keep them in pain keep
them all those survival emotions you'll
never have Community you bring people
into an elevated emotional state
something innate in the human species
says we're empathic to one another and
we celebrate one another we want to get
along with one another we want to
cooperate we want to resolve issues
together that's that's who we are when
we're not living in stress and survival
if you think about gratitude when when
you receive something favorable or you
just receive something favorable if
something's happening to you or
something just happened to you that you
are excited about you feel grateful so
the emotional signature of gratitude
means that it's already happened or
something wonderful is happening to you
now the body is so objective
that it does not know the difference
between a real life experience that's
creating that emotion and that emotion
that you're fabricating by thought alone
so the body's believing it's living in
an environmental condition that's
favorable to you
and we only accept believe and surrender
to thoughts that are equal to our
emotional state so in the state of
gratitude your body is more prone to be
programmed through its autonomic nervous
system into a different Destiny and the
research that we've done uh in our in
our on our research team shows that just
four days of feeling gratitude
can strengthen your immune system by 50
percent by releasing a an immunoglobulin
called immunoglobulin a which is their
body's primary defense against bacteria
and viruses is better than any flu shot
and it's the body's natural capacity so
so when we trade
anger and frustration and fear and
anxiety and pain and suffering and guilt
for an elevated emotion the autonomic
nervous system starts to regulate back
into homeostasis imbalance and of course
stress is when the autonomic nervous
system is knocked out of homeostasis
imbalance it's dysregulation so we teach
people how to give thanks for the things
that they create in their life actually
before it happens and when we do that
properly
we start to see measurable changes in
the person's body and measurable changes
in their energy and ultimately
measurable changes in their life so the
concept of presence is such an important
concept because I think that paying
attention is being present and it's a
skill just like anything else the more
you practice it the better you get at it
and I think we know when people are
present with us in our lives is because
they're paying attention to us and we
know when they're not present with us
because they're not paying attention
well where you place your attention is
where you place your energy bottom line
so if you're thinking about what's going
to happen in the next moment or what's
going to happen in a day or you're
reviewing what's something that happened
three days ago you're placing your
attention in some future scenario or
some past memory and we siphon energy
out of the present moment and we don't
have available energy then to really
begin to create an outcome in our lives
but if we're truly present and we're
relaxed and poised in the present moment
if where you place your attention is
where you place your energy then you
have a lot of energy in the present
moment to execute a lot of energy in the
present moment to make decisions the
more you do this the more you experience
those moments of flow the
synchronicities the serendipities the
opportunities the coincidences because
there's a lot of power in the present
moment so one of the key elements in the
creative process is teaching people how
to relax into the present moment so if a
person is thinking about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in their brain that are connected
to certain people and objects and things
at certain times and places the moment
they think about their problems say
first thing in the morning when they
wake up
if you believe your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny and
your brain is a record of the past the
moment you remember your problems you're
thinking in the past and because every
problem has an emotion Associated
because you experience it the moment you
feel unhappy now your body's in the past
so thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so most
people
unconsciously start their day
with their entire state of being
biologically in the past and again the
body's so objective it doesn't know the
difference between the real life
experience uh and the emotion that
you're creating by thought alone so that
past that familiar past is called the
known and if you wake up in the morning
and you start thinking about
the predictable future and the people
you have to see and the places you have
to go and the things you have to do in
your routine predictable life
the same exact thing happens you're
you're imagining that future scenario
that's already known to you
and you're anticipating the feeling of
that outcome
so that becomes the predictable future
becomes the known as well so if the
familiar past is the known and the
predictable future is the known there's
only one place where the unknown exists
and that's the sweet spot of the
generous present moment in teaching
people how to create from the present
moment is what begins to produce the
magic and the changes that take place in
their lives in order to create a new
future
to change something in your life nothing
changes
in your life until you change that's uh
that's the story right so then the
question is okay is in order for me to
create something new I'm going to have
to combine a clear intention that's a
function of the brain and the mind
that's a a process that you can get
better at and you got to combine that
with an elevated emotion and that means
then you can't wait for your healing to
feel grateful you can't wait for your
new relationship to feel love you can't
wait for your uh um
wealth to feel abundance you know that's
that's the old model of reality of cause
and effect in fact
we're going to teach people actually how
to feel the emotion before it happens
and when you combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion
that's going to require your heart to
move into balance and move into order it
turns out that's a skill too that you
can practice
so then when you combine those two
elements so that clear intention with
the elevated emotion and you can sustain
that for a period of time
the coherence in the brain the coherence
and the Heart actually act like a Wi-Fi
signal you're starting to put out a
Broadband spectrum of frequency and
energy that causes you to feel connected
to something and now you're no longer
trying to get something done or waiting
for something in your outer World to
Change to take away the emptiness or
lack you're feeling because you don't
have the experience yet if people can
actually feel the feelings of the
emotions before the experience happens
they wouldn't be looking for it because
they would feel like it already happened
right so they teach people how to
sustain these states and if they can
the side effect of that is that you
start seeing synchronicities in your
life those serendipities those
coincidences those opportunities that
you're no longer going anywhere to get
them and you're not trying to control
the outcome or Force the outcome or
fight for the outcome or predict the
outcome or compete for it that's that's
when we're matter trying to change
matter when you synchronize your energy
into a possibility in your life and you
start seeing those synchronicities in
your life now when you start seeing
those opportunities occurring you're
just going to start paying attention to
what you've been doing and do more of it
and you go then from being the victim of
your life to being the creator of your
life and the cool part about it is you
don't have to go anywhere to get it
somehow out of nowhere it seems to come
to you and those moments are moments of
Awakening so the formula really is about
combining quantum physics with
Neuroscience with neuroendocrinology
with psychonur Immunology with
electromagnetism epigenetics all of
these different branches of science to
build a model to show people that you
actually can be the creator of your life
I travel around the world and I have the
opportunity to talk to all kinds of
people and one of the things that
independent of people's beliefs
political beliefs religious beliefs
whatever there seems to be a Common
Thread that people feel like something's
not right
and I think when
um you get to a point where you realize
that no health care plan no government
no religion is going to take care of you
then who is going to take care of you
and the answer is you right
so my interest is uh to give people the
tools and the understanding that they
could heal their body that they could
create a better life for themselves
that they could overcome past traumas
and scars that were created even as
early as childhood that tend to be
unconscious programs that keep them
repeating the same you know scenarios in
their life
to teach people how to induce mystical
experiences so that it changes the frame
of what the way they look at reality
and so what an amazing time in history
to be alive because Consciousness is
awareness
and awareness is paying attention and
paying attention is noticing so so if a
person lives a life as an example
and is diagnosed with a health condition
their what they're conscious of
is just a certain number of choices that
they could make based on the past based
on tradition based on what's worked for
normal or natural
but what happens when that person has
done the chemotherapy has done the
surgery has done the radiation has done
the vegan diet has done the gluten-free
diet has done the ketogenic diet has
done all the things all the exercise
and they still have the same health
condition
it begs the question
if our personality creates our personal
reality
and our personality is made up of how we
think how we act and how we feel
then the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life not their ex not their
parents not their culture they create
their life so the fundamental question
is if if
I want to change my life
then that means that I have to change or
nothing changes in my life until I
change right so the person who's done
all these treatments and still faced
with a health condition this is just an
example
all of a sudden says there's got to be
another way there's got to be something
else and so knowledge information
when we learn knowledge we learn
information we make new Connections in
our brain that's what learning is we're
forging synaptic connections
but that philosophical theoretical
intellectual information is void of
experience
someone who takes that knowledge and
applies it and personalizes demonstrates
it initiates that knowledge
is now interested in the truth of the
experience of that information
so the person then who becomes conscious
that they could actually heal themselves
by changing the way they think the way
they act the way they feel if I truly go
into the experiment of no longer
thinking the same way no longer acting
the same way no longer feeling the same
way and I start thinking about what
thoughts I do want to fire and wire in
my brain
and if I do it with intention and
attention I'll begin to install
neurological Hardware keep doing it and
becomes like a software program it
becomes a new voice in your head that
goes from I can't to I can
no magic there if you said how would
greatness live today how what would love
look like today what would be a greater
expression of myself in the things that
I do
turns out if you close your eyes and you
rehearse in your mind
how you're going to be
in any aspect of your day if you're
truly present the brain doesn't know the
difference between the inward experience
of what you're imagining and the outer
real experience it look the brain looks
like you've already done it the brain
looks like it's already experiencing now
do that enough times the hardware
becomes a software program and you start
behaving like a different person super
athletes do this this is musicians
athletes dancers everybody who's good at
something is always rehearsing in their
mind
that that rehearsal is just as important
as the physical demonstration it's
priming the brain because the brain is a
record of the past now you're actually
making it a map to the Future you're
installing circuits to use
if you said God I live my whole life in
guilt I didn't know it was guilt uh in
shame or unworthiness unself-doubt and
security fear and all of a sudden you're
looking at that emotion you understand
that emotion is actually down regulating
genes and creating disease you figure
that out you read about it it makes
sense then all of the hatred all the
anger all the bitterness you have to
someone or something in your past
is keeping you connected to the past so
you'd say
can I teach my body emotionally what a
new future could feel like before it
happens not waiting for your wealth to
feel abundance or waiting for your
relationship to feel love or waiting for
your healing to feel gratitude that's
the old model of reality of cause and
effect this is about causing an effect
turns out if you can elevate your
emotional state
and you can sustain that emotional state
your body's so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating that
emotion
and that emotion that you're creating by
thought alone your body's actually
believing it's living in a new reality
in new environments now the environment
signals the gene the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion that person is actually
signaling genes ahead of the environment
genes make proteins and proteins are
responsible for the structure and
functional body the expression of
proteins is the expression of life okay
every day the person practices going
from the old self to the new self this
is what's happening in the world right
now
as they start to change and they start
unfiring and unwiring and they stop
conditioning the body emotionally for
the past and practice this
they emerge as a new personality they
become somebody else and like magic
the disease exists in the old person
and there's somebody else now here's
where Consciousness comes in
that person comes to a workshop and they
stand on the stage in front of 1500
people and they tell their story
and everybody in that audience is
leaning in
why because they're looking at truth
they're looking at the someone who just
got healed from a chronic uh chronic I'm
talking about stage four cancers I'm
talking about Parkinson's disease I'm
talking about rare genetic disorders
and now the person in the audience is
becoming conscious
of a possibility that they were once
unconscious to And when they see that's
possible it's a four minute mile I mean
four minute mile nobody thought anybody
could break a mile and under performance
they said it was biological yeah
physiologically impossible 1400 people
have done it already so this is the four
minute mile someone's piercing through a
limitation the level of unconsciousness
and now that's a footprint in the
quantum field but in three-dimensional
reality you're looking at that person
they look no different than anybody else
and the person says
if that person can do it I can do it as
well I think the ego is something that
is healthy when it's in Balance like if
I have a bonfire in my backyard and
those and the Flames are getting a
little bit too big and there's ashes and
sparks flying off the bonfire your ego
says David step back you know it's it's
preservational wants to take care of the
body if we're hiking on a cliff and we
come to a very narrow path and it's a
thousand foot drop your ego is going to
say stay close to the wall don't go out
to the edge you could be injured and be
heard so the egos has a function to
really in a sense be analytical and and
weigh what we know against what we don't
know and it's healthy the problem is is
when it's driven by the hormones of
stress and stress is when your body's
knocked out of balance it's not that
knocked out of order that state actually
causes you to be altered and there'll
always be a gap between the way things
appear or the way you appear and the way
things really are you're in an altered
state now for the short term that's
great all organisms can tolerate that
but if you keep doing that for an
extended period of time the arousal
that's created from the stress hormones
actually causes the analytical mind all
of a sudden to go into overdrive so now
the endorsement of the ego becomes
enhanced and we become selfish that's
what it does it causes it causes us to
be self-indulgent to be self-centered to
be self-important be self-apprandizing
to be full of self-pity because in
stress there's only one thing that's
important when you're in survival and
that's you and so all of our attention
goes on our body all of our attention
goes on all the elements in our
environment and we come become very
preoccupied with time now
when we're in balance
and there's order in the autonomic
nervous system there's health
and if stress is when you move out of
balance autonomic dysregulation then you
are altered from wholeness you are you
are separate from uh everyone and
everything in your life and you tend to
trust less it's not a time to open your
heart in the jungle the survival Gene is
switched on you you don't communicate
very well you're looking at how you can
get to where you need to be or
accomplish what you need to do first and
you got to be there first and compete
because this is all driven by those
stress hormones so the ego becomes out
of balance now here's the cool part
about all of this
when people are driven by those stress
hormones and they don't know how to
change it they don't know how to
self-regulate again it's not that you
react the question is how long are you
going to react if they don't know how to
do that
the problem with most people is they
start analyzing their life
within the emotion that's disturbing
them now emotions are a record of the
past so what we see on brain scans over
and over again when you start over
analyzing and overthinking in a selfish
way
100 of the time you'll make your brain
worse and that will have dramatic
effects on your body so when the heart
is racing because it's pumping blood but
you're sitting in a zoom call and you're
smiling and you're looking at that
person a zoom calling you're thinking
about ways to murder them you're
producing those chemicals but you're not
running and you're not fighting and
you're not hiding so what happens is the
heart is pumping against a very closed
system and it moves out of order it
moves out of balance and now the
autonomic nervous system which controls
and coordinates all other systems in
your body
is out of balance and that dysregulation
causes disease so then the fundamental
question is okay can I trade fear can I
trade anger can I trade competition can
I trade frustration resentment in
patience hostility uh hopelessness
powerlessness Whatever anxiety for an
elevated emotion can I learn how to
dial down those stress hormones and
practice feeling elevated emotions turns
out
you can do that now the real question is
when you're in your heart you're not so
selfish in fact when there's a change in
blood flow to the heart and oxytocin and
nitric oxide is released you tend to
want to give you you tend to want to
consider the whole and you lead with
your heart
you're not separate from anybody you're
you're functioning as a community so I
think then that
um our future as as human beings is that
we have to be able to live in an
elevated state in our hearts and if we
fall from grace back into those survival
emotions the key is to be able to
self-regulate and get so good at it in
your meditation with your eyes closed so
good at it that you can do it with your
eyes open now that's when the game
becomes really really important so uh
when people do the work and they do
their meditations and they come up
against themselves gosh I want them to I
want them to come up against their fear
and in the in the week-long workshops I
want them to come up against their
impatience I want all those thoughts
that come up that say I can't it's too
hard I'll never change it's my ex's
fault it's my boss's fault I want those
thoughts to be right in their face and I
want to give them tools to let them know
that right on the other side of that
that thought right on the other side of
that propensity to want to get up and
quit right on the other side of that
emotion that's keeping them connected to
the past if they're willing to sit in
the fire
to sit with themselves and instead of
getting up and quitting on themselves
learn how to self-regulate and create
brain and heart coherence I guarantee
you every time they go a little further
and they produce those victories of
those victories add up so what's the
side effect of that you return back to
your life you don't need jerk as much
why because you just overcame some part
of your aggression and anger by sitting
with your body and like training an
animal
training a dog I don't know training the
servant to be present to to to to to to
be greater than the body as the mind to
execute a will that's greater than those
unconscious programs and what we found
out is when people actually apply some
type of formula to be able to do this
every time they bring the body back into
the present moment it starts liberating
energy
so there goes the frustration there goes
the impatience and all of a sudden the
unknown which tends to be such a scary
place for most people is the present
moment you see the side effect of that
as the person's more present they're
less preoccupied with all the things
that people spend most of their
attention on now so you overcome the ego
you overcome the personality uh uh
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
that you got to be able to lay it down
and as you temper your body and your
mind
um the ego tends to be less selfish and
more selfless and then the side effect
of that is that then if I say hey look
at David he's actually doing it I'm
gonna try it too because he's he's doing
it and research and Neuroscience says
you hang out with people that do things
you start your brain synchronizes and
you start doing those same things it's
called an emergence emergence that's the
birds all moving in the same direction
it's a school of fish moving is one mind
and one heart if you study that you
think there's one leader like that
everybody's following a leader like a
top-down phenomenon it's actually wrong
it's a bottom-up phenomenon everybody's
leading so the way we change the world
then is that you work on yourself I'll
work on myself we get to show up and
bring our best and when we're not at our
best we excuse ourselves get back to
that state and we present ourselves back
to the world and I think this is such a
great time in history where people
really need some tools to be able to
cope with with all all the challenges in
the world I think there's this feeling
that we all have
that never seems to go away and it's an
intuition it's an instinct that tells us
that there's more to reality than this
dream and and I think that people come
to this work for that feeling
and I think that we're greater than we
think more powerful than we know more
unlimited than we could ever dream and
my passion
my interest is to take science and
combine quantum physics with
Neuroscience with neuroendocrinology
with
psychoneuroimmunology with uh the
epigenetics electromagnetism and I think
science is that language to demystify
the mystical
and to build models of understanding
from a theoretical and intellectual
knowledge-based analytical perspective
but
that knowledge void of experience is
philosophy but if you can teach people
how to practically apply it to to
personalize it to demonstrate it to
initiate that knowledge
and do something with it
if they can get their behaviors to match
their intentions or their actions equal
to their thoughts if they get their mind
and body working together they're going
to have an experience right and it turns
out that learning information makes
Connections in the brain but experience
enriches those connections well the
moment those neurons string into place
there's a biological change that takes
place in the brain another part of the
brain makes a chemical and that chemical
is called an emotion and the moment you
feel successful the moment you feel
empowered the moment you feel Unlimited
I think now you're teaching your body
chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood so knowledge
is for the mind and experiences for the
body and so what we learned in this
whole process of transformation is that
the more people understand what they're
doing
and why they're doing it the how gets
easier so when the experience then is
causes them to embody the truth of that
philosophy it's no longer theoretical
it's experiential and it's visceral so
the experience then
produces a strong emotion and the
emotion then is what is the information
coming uh back to the body that begins
to select and instruct new genes and
we've measured this on people that they
could actually change their gene
expression in in three or four days by
doing this now if you've done it once
it means you got to be able to do it
again right so anybody who's serious
about their own personal growth and
evolution
the replication of any experience will
begin to both neurologically and
chemically condition the mind and body
to work as one so when you've done
something so many times that your body
now knows how to do it better than your
conscious mind now it's innating you
it's implicit it's automatic it's second
nature it's easy you've become the
knowledge and in a sense you've mastered
that knowledge and you're in a new state
of being so
my interest is demystify that process so
that people have within their reach all
the tools begin to apply it to their
lives if you think that your thoughts
have something to do with your future
just from a theoretical standpoint that
your thoughts Create Your Destiny and
you think sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts in one day and ninety percent
of those thoughts are the same thoughts
as the day before
well then your life isn't going to
change very much as long as you're
thinking the same way and those those
same thoughts lead to the same choices
the same choices lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
exact same experiences and we anticipate
the same feelings or emotions from those
experiences and those emotions are the
payoff that drive our very same thoughts
while our biology our neurosircuitry
neural chemistry our hormones and even
our gene expression will be equal to how
we think how we act and how we feel and
how we think how we act and how we feel
is called our personality and our
personality creates our personal reality
that's it so the present personality
who's listening to this show has created
the present personal reality called
their life so if you can latch on to
this idea if you want to create a new
life a new personal reality you got to
change your personality which means you
better start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and changing it you
begin to become conscious of your
unconscious actions or habits or
behaviors and modify them
and then we have to begin to look at the
emotions that we live by every single
day
that'll keep us connected to the past
and decide do these emotions belong in
our future so most people are trying to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right and
pychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then
that kind of box in the brain that is
the habit of ourselves it's uh we're 95
of the time running a series of programs
so then sitting and doing the work had
we have to become disentangled from
those programs and so the moment you
decide to do something differently or
make a new choice but most people don't
want to face is that discomfort and that
that discomfort that that uncertainty
that lack of predictability the that
that that unknown is what people are
afraid of because they'd rather live in
guilt at least they can predict who
they're going to be then take a chance
and possibility so when a person begins
to understand this and you say well
how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and
you say why 35 years because 35 years
ago I had this one event well the
stronger the emotion you feel from the
reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion because it's the emotion that
keeps you anchored to the past so that
sounds really good theoretically but
when you step out into that unknown into
that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and it's producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they'd rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy
then be in this this comfort so then at
least then when they return back to that
familiar feeling then they feel safe so
they step out in the unknown and the
body starts influencing the mind saying
you can start tomorrow you're too busy
it's your mother's fault you know it's
your culture's fault I don't have enough
money this isn't going to work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then
to meditate it means to become familiar
with so as you become familiar with
those thoughts you become conscious of
how you speak you become aware of how
you act you notice how you're feeling
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious programs the less
unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why because it's not enough to just have
a great meditation and get up and get on
the freeway and get in traffic I'm
getting stressed you just return back to
the old self again our job then
is to sustain that modified State of
Mind and Body the entire day and if you
can get ready because something
different or unusual is going to begin
to happen in your life and it will come
as a coincidence or a synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then to understand that
there's a formula that we now know that
if you apply that formula you'll begin
to see those changes and now as people
are doing it more and more
effectively the results are going up as
well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which
uh the community can change brain or
heart coherence they they know how to do
it it's not uh something that's that's
separate from them they've practiced it
enough times that they they now know how
to do it so what's the significance of
that well really simple
in your life
if you start returning back to the same
reactions to the same people and
circumstances you're returning back to
the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological a
biological chemical a hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work you can't tell me you
had a turbulent past or or that you're
too overweight or too underweight or too
out of shape or you can't even tell me
that you've never meditated before in
fact some of our greatest
scans or people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 in not 60 and we do a
week-long event we got a thousand people
or 1500 people and they are all in and
that when they start getting Beyond
themselves that first day or second day
once they start getting Beyond
themselves and that magic starts to
happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting we
do have beliefs that feel good to us
because those beliefs are based on past
experiences and those emotions keep us
attached to the belief chemically it's
in our biology and we tend to think
neurologically and feel chemically
within experiences then that are
connected to the past so when our
beliefs are challenged we hold on to the
emotion like Jesus had a brother what
that doesn't feel right you know he was
married to Mary Magdalene that's you
know I mean people freak out because
they've been conditioned and they want
to hold on to that because that then
ensures a future that they can rely on
when you step out of your belief systems
and stepping into the unknown
you are now leaving behind your past and
then so then do you have the faculty
and the ability to create
do you have that ability if not because
then in order for you to go from that
Old belief to a new belief then you
better have a plan and you better be
willing to have a new experience that is
no longer a wishy-washy belief
it has to be
a very strong impression in your biology
it comes with an accompanying experience
that then changes your biology to
understand you believe something else
but that's not the end either because
then you have the question from that
point
what is the next belief that helps you
to understand the next thing for example
let's talk about it on two levels and
time out here for a second I don't care
we can go to 11 30 here oh beautiful
thank you so much
it was a good conversation so think
about this
the person in our work
who I'll use a simple example
has a uh very very difficult marriage
and her marriage falls apart her husband
was abusive
and lived by the stress hormones for
extended period of time of course all
our energy is going for some threat in
our external environment she has no
energy in him her internal environment
for growth and repair no energy for
long-term building projects the the body
is in vigilance it's it's always anxious
she's anticipating something bad
happening all the time and she's got
food allergies to
everything
she's allergic to her environment
she comes to the event she does the work
it takes her three months and all of a
sudden in one event she has a
breakthrough and she's eating anything
she wants now she's changed her belief
about her past because she's no longer
saying I am this way because of my
relationship with my husband because
when you say I am this way because I had
an abusive father I am this way because
I had a difficult marriage I am this way
because I got fired from my job what
you're saying is I haven't changed since
that event emotionally
and so now you're viewing your future
through the lens of the past when you
overcome that emotional state a memory
without the emotional charge is called
wisdom
now you're ready to create a new future
because if you're still attached to the
emotion you're still attached to the
past and you can't create a future so
all of a sudden now the person has a
transformation
she had a shift she knows that she knows
that she's liberated from that anxiety
she's she feels it and as a result of it
in a matter of moments Banner biology
reorganizes to a new mind and now she's
I'm watching her eat pizza I'm watching
her eat a hamburger I'm she's laughing
she's and it's and it's sustained
but that's not the end because if she
healed herself then the next question is
I understand the physics and biology of
what I've done is it possible if I heal
myself
but I can heal another person
now my my belief is being challenged
again now I'm challenging my current
belief is it possible well I don't know
I haven't had the experience yet but if
I'm thinking it and I understand the
semantic philosophical theoretical
intellectual information can I initiate
it can I apply it can I personalize it
can I demonstrate it can I modify my
behavior in some way based on my last
experience to have a more evolved
experience and that more evolved
experience will be outside of my beliefs
currently but I understand the science
and if I can get my behaviors to match
my intentions and I've done it to myself
and quantum physics says is that
Consciousness is non-local will help if
I can create a coherent signature here I
should be able to do it in another
person
so then when the when the experience
occurs
now I have more circuitry in my brain
that's enriched I have a new feeling in
my body and I feel like a Healer I
already feel like a Healer because I've
healed myself but let me see if I can
heal someone else I'm going to bring up
that emotion and it may take me a few
times and I'm telling you that woman we
did a coherent session where we're
healing another person and the person
laying down there was a woman who from
London who had a exposure to a bacteria
in India 20 years ago who had food
allergies That Couldn't overcome that
bacteria and I watched this woman
synchronistically
unbeknownst to the woman laying down
there lay a coherent energy in that
person's body and that woman was healed
I had dinner with her in London and she
was eating salmon and rice and
everything else and she said I don't
know what happened but I got healed now
that person who did the healing
her belief was challenged and because
she had the experience she asked the
greater question so the greater question
then led to the next experience but it's
not enough to do it once
you got to be able to repeat that
experience you got to make it scientific
right you got to get you're going to
make it a skill and this is where people
stop like they have the one experience
and say I'm a Healer no
the fact that you have the experience
means you should be able to reproduce
that
so then you keep pushing the boundaries
of your beliefs that's called Evolution
and so people reach a certain point in
their belief systems and they stop and
so I think the problem with a lot of
people in the spiritual Community is
they confuse Insight with belief like oh
you know I had a I have an I have
anxiety so the reason I have anxiety
because I have a chemical imbalance in
my brain that's what my doctor told me
and I get panic attacks and I got a
panic attack on a plane and I'm afraid
of planes and crowded places and so now
that you know that you have a chemical
imbalance in your brain does it heal
your anxiety no so then they go to the
they go to the psychologist they go to
their friend their friend says well it's
not a hardware problem it's not circuits
and molecules and chemicals
software problem you know your father
was overbearing he was a perfectionist
and and it's a soft it's a programming
you know it's from your past and
the person now has the insight
that their father was overbearing does
it heal the anxiety but they will see
that as a belief like my father was
overbearing what they're really saying
is I am this way because of this past
experience so then they go to the
psychic and the psychic says you were
burned at the stake in Carcassonne in
the 1500s you're a Charismatic Christian
the memories burned in your soul now
that you know that you are a Charismatic
Christian from the 1500s a cathar a
Templar does it heal your anxiety no so
then you go to the astrologer and she
says you know Mercury is in retrograde
don't leave the house for six months
it's the reason Ari the way you are the
way you are and so they develop beliefs
that are within their emotional
acceptance and so then they build more
beliefs within those emotions which
means I still don't want to change the
Insight doesn't change anything because
people will only accept believe and
surrender
to beliefs or thoughts that are equal to
their emotional state and they'll
program their autonomic nervous system
into that Destiny so then you get a
diagnosis from a doctor it creates the
emotion of fear or desperation you'll
only accept belief and surrender to the
thoughts equal to those emotional states
until you change your emotional state is
it possible for you then to begin to
accept believe and surrender their
thoughts equal to a new emotional state
and bring up the emotion ahead of the
experience now we're talking about
going against conditioning when you
teach people how to connect to the
energy of a future dream and be defined
by a vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past to believe in their
future more than they believe in their
past
to fall in love with their future more
than they fall in love with their past
and be able to combine that clear
intention of that future
and begin to feel the emotions of that
future before it's made manifest they're
broadcasting a whole new signature into
the field now the beauty behind that is
is that the longer you're conscious of
that energy
the more you're drawing that future to
you
which also means then the moment you get
in your car and start getting angry and
getting frustrated because you're in
traffic
now you just disconnected from the
energy of your future and now you're
back to the energy of your past and
those survival emotions exert less
effects on the nature of reality so now
you feel like matter trying to change
matter you're you're separate and so you
force it you control it you try harder
you wish you pray you hope I mean hope
is a beggar we do everything compete to
try to manipulate and make it happen
because we have limited resources then
so then when a person is able to sustain
or maintain that modified state of mind
and being
then the fun starts to happen because
you start seeing those synchronicities
you start seeing those coincidences
those opportunities those unknowns those
things start falling out of nowhere
because you are connected to that field
of information and not only are you
connected to it but you're also
beginning to influence it so then more
and more people are creating now and
less of less people are experiencing the
state of being called being a victim so
then if you're a victim then you would
say I was angry because of traffic well
then I would say to you well you mean
your outer world was controlling how you
think and feel some circumstance some
person something in your outer world is
actually controlling your feelings and
thoughts that means you're a victim to
those circumstances but when you change
the way you think and feel and it starts
to produce effects in your outer world
now you start to realize you're the
creator of your life and the moment you
start seeing feedback in your life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
and now you're going to believe now
you're more of the creator of your life
and less of the victim of your life so
you ask yourself at the end of your day
I do this every day how'd I do how'd I
do today bro how'd you do just do good
where'd you fall from grace what what
what was it that caused you to go
unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student of
Life you'll begin to contemplate well it
was that person that said that thing
then I reacted or this I got this email
or things didn't go my way and I started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens how could I
involve my experience now you may have
to search for some answers of the best
model to build or you may actually have
a long contemplation and start to go God
the next time that happens I think I'm
gonna do this or I'm gonna do that or
I'm going to plan my behaviors and the
act of closing your eyes and rehearsing
what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the Future and if you keep
installing that Hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important
than the news right it's more important
than answering any email or any text
it's more important than talking about
your past or some dinner if you can
begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you gotta close
your door you gotta take a break from
everything out there and begin to
practice and so by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear and now we've given people the
tools to be able to self-regulate to
create brain and heart coherence and so
you see people say excuse me one minute
I just need a minute it takes some
breaths they get back in they connect to
the energy of their future this is
incidental compared to where they're
going so they don't fall from grace they
don't allow their energy to drop and so
yeah in the beginning it takes a lot
because it takes a lot of energy and
awareness to stay conscious and not go
unconscious but if you're persistent and
you're determined then you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say I am not going to give my power away
to that person or that circumstance when
I can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then won't excuse
themselves and say I had a hard day
yesterday at a fight with my co-worker
or my ex or and I don't feel like doing
the work well that's the time they get
back on the horse yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct
those are the most valuable moments thus
people who have had profoundly
transcendental experiences where they we
say got lit up they connected and their
brain goes into very very high coherent
States and super gamma patterns that are
way outside of normal and they have a
transcendental downloader connection
that's mystical they look back at their
entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past because it got them to that
moment that's the moment the past no
longer exists now by the same means they
look back at their past and they see all
those tough moments where they overcame
themselves and they fall in love with
that person they don't look at the good
meditations or the things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
I I think then that's when they begin to
understand that that all of the hard
work
all the effort in who we become makes no
one can take that away from us so then
once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else yeah
and I think that's Evolution meditation
the actual translation of the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation if people
are really really believing that their
astrological sign determines their
Destiny then they will look for based on
their perception the correlations that
are equal to their belief system I don't
particularly believe that because I'm
born at a certain time under certain
house that has anything to do with me
creating the life that I want to have
right so
many people will though and because they
do they'll only they'll select like oh I
saw 11 11 on the clock well
well you've seen three 236 on the clock
and 4 18 on the clock but you're looking
for 11 11. well then that's your reality
because that's where your attention is
right so I don't subscribe to that but I
respect that because that person is
going to keep that belief until it no
longer serves them and they're either
going to evolve their belief or they're
not and if they don't so be it but if
they do they're going to realize sooner
or later it's not working for them I
have certain beliefs right now
that I honestly am questioning that I
still think are limited beliefs but in
order for me to change those beliefs I'm
going to have to come out of my resting
state have to step out into the unknown
and really check to see and execute in a
very different way now
to build on that model
then it's going to require one foot
in the Practical world and one foot in
the Mysterious World because I can't
control all the events that happen in my
life but I can certainly make choices
that are going to bring me closer to
those experiences now I also know from
experience that when I'm living by the
hormones of stress and I'm living in
survival that you and I and everybody
else is always going to try to control
the outcome to try to force the outcome
to try to get in the way try to analyze
when it's going to happen and how it's
going to happen now when that occurs
we're really bad
we're competitive we're manipulative
we'll hold on the things we're deceitful
we're greedy because that's what those
chemicals do so we're always trying to
control and force the outcome because in
a sense we feel separate from something
greater we feel like we're matter trying
to change matter we feel like uh we're
we're vibrating at the same speed as
everything else and so we have to get
what we want means we have to go and get
it and and and so then people start
mixing spiritual principles with that
phenomenon right so then
that's not what I'm talking about
because I'm talking about
if you're able
to understand that when you're living by
the hormones of stress that your senses
are heightened
and that your materialist trying to
Define reality if you can't see it feel
a taste it smell it doesn't exist and
you're getting ready for something bad
to happen and be prepared and protect
yourself and that's how most people live
then everybody's doing that everybody's
mad at trying to change matter and soon
we're going to bump into each other and
there's going to be Sparks right so then
is it possible then
that instead of being defined as a body
living in an environment in a particular
time
that if you were to close your eyes and
disconnect from the external environment
to sit your body down
into transcend time
and to become nobody
you have the biological Machinery to do
this to become no one you're not a face
you're not a man you're not a
documentary filmmaker
you're not your past you're not your
future you're not a husband
you're not your body you're not your
emotions you're not your habits you're
not the predictable future of the
familiar past
your pure consciousness
now if you are going to heal your body
by thought alone
if you are going to create some event in
your external environment by thought
alone and if you are going to transcend
Time by thought alone then you have to
become thought alone
and so when people start to really
realize that they can change the neural
circuitry in their brain by thought
alone send new emotional signals that
begin to select and up regulate new
genes and down regulate other genes and
it may take knocking on that door
for extended periods of time to finally
the gene is programmed because it took
them 10 years to program the gene for
the disease it may take them a few years
to reprogram the gene
now we're talking about pragmatist we're
talking about someone who's applying
some principles and so then when that
occurs
and the energy that was sitting in these
hormonal centers of survival of anger
and fear and guilt and shame the energy
kind of moves up a little bit we've
measured This Heart starts to open gets
more coherent the field around the body
begins to grow we've measured that the
person feels more like energy less like
matter they feel like more like wave
less like particle they're not afraid of
the unknown they let's go ahead and
answer that really quick he said like
the greatest part right now
he said knocking on the door I was like
Yeah ironic
oh thank you
all right hopefully you didn't lose your
train of thought so
they're not afraid of the unknown
they're craving and they're trusting in
the unknown
and that that kind of expanded energy
is now their no longer
enslaved emotionally to the Past they're
no longer an identity that's connected
to a disease they're no longer a body
who's addicted to an emotion they're no
longer trying to forecast the future
based on the past they're no longer a
man they're no longer a woman they're no
longer a nurse they're no longer black
they're no longer white they're no
longer anything
they're they're a they are completely
poised in the present moment and that
that
present moment produces a liberation of
energy because the body is no longer
held to the chains of the past and that
liberation of energy then begins to
produce a biological transformation in
the brain and the body we've seen it the
brain gets highly coherent gets super
organized the person feels whole
we've measured that their heart moves
into a state of joy and and love and
gratitude we measured that the field
around their bodies enhanced we measure
that and the person could no longer
cares about the future of the past
they're happy in the present moment they
no longer want anything because they're
whole
and if you're whole it's impossible to
want and that's the moment it happens
and so kind of this Paradox that begins
to occur so why am I explaining it like
this because I want to answer the
ultimate question of what you're asking
is that there's an intelligence that's
giving us life
it's keeping my heart beating and
digesting my food and food and
organizing trillions of functions per
second in every cell of my body I'm not
doing that I'm having a conversation
with you as a free-willed subject of
consciousness
but there is an intelligence within me
that's always endorsing who I'm being
and that intelligence is a Giver of Life
so to demystify it then
and this is where
i s i part from the spiritual community
because when your will
matches its will
when your mind matches its mind when
your love for Life matches its love for
life it begins to work in ways that are
mysterious now
why is that important because the
mysterious is the unknown and the
unknown is unexpected and the unexpected
should bring a surprise and that
surprise should be outside of my current
beliefs if it's happening how could I
expect the supernatural to happen if I'm
expecting it to happen
it's impossible but if I'm in the
unknown and I'm open
to possibility then I should be able to
create an unknown experience that I
can't predict the emotion or the future
event of how it's going to occur when
it's going to occur it's not my job and
the side effect of that is this
mysterious surprise that changes my
biology from the new experience and then
causes me to change my beliefs and I've
I've had enough of my own mystical
moments
in the midst of that mystical experience
I have said in the midst of it I have
this all wrong I have said it right in
the midst of the experiment I am doing
this so wrong because I was so
programmed into this box of belief
but the only way the unexpected could
happen
is giving up expectation which means you
have to surrender that belief how it's
going to happen or when it's going to
happen I can't predict that so then that
same intelligence that's giving me life
according to the quantum model of
reality is the same intelligence that's
creating supernovas and causing flowers
to bloom it's it's within us and all
around us it's it's a very wave of
quantum physics I can't control that I
can't expect how the particle is going
to appear or when it's going to appear
but it's not my job
my job is to move into different states
of being and be open to the mystery of
how it's going to happen so
if I said to you today Ben that I had
all the answers
to everything I would I would certainly
be limiting this conversation but I am
open to the to the mystery of life and
the Mystery of Life then means that if
we're asking certain questions and we
believe we we even speculate that it's
possible and someone has to step out
into out of their present beliefs to see
if it is
and so I'm not interested in the natural
I'm not interested in the normal
I'm interested in the Supernatural the
super normal and I believe from my
present state of ignorance of course if
we're going to use the word belief that
you don't have to be a Buddhist monk
you don't have to be a nun with 40 Years
of devotion you don't have to be a
religious scholar you don't have to be a
researcher you don't have to have a PhD
to do this
that common people around the world can
do the uncommon and if they're given the
right understanding
and the environment is set up where they
can begin the application of that
and I have looked at over a thousand
brain scans of people in meditation
and I can tell you that you and I are at
our absolute best when we get beyond our
analytical mind when we get Beyond
ourselves that's the moment
that the brain gets so organized and so
coherent from the brain is talking to
the back of the brain the right side of
the brain is talking on the left side of
the brain there's this synchronization
this psychic Union going on a flow
and the person has tears of joy rolling
down their face that Gestalt moment
that that
Transcendent event for the person is
completely subjective but my interest is
measuring that subjective experience and
we're capturing amplitudes of energy in
people's brains that are 26 000 to 40
000 times normal during that experience
now
they can't make their brain do that it's
happening to them
and the inner event that's happening to
them is more real than any past event
and that's the moment I know their
belief is changing can you teach your
body emotionally
what the future reality that you want to
live in feels like before it happens now
this is very difficult if you've been
conditioned into believing something in
your outer world has to change to make a
way take away the emptiness or the lack
to make you feel differently this is
saying actually feel the emotion before
it happens and don't wait for the
experience to occur teach your body what
the feeling will be before it occurs if
the environment signals the Gene and the
end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion you're
signaling the gene ahead of the
environment and genes make proteins and
proteins are responsible for the
structure and function of your body and
the expression of proteins is the
expression of life so teach the body
emotionally to self-regulate to believe
it's living in an environment that's
flourishing that's wonderful keep
practicing it and it'll become familiar
to you and the process then
creates a new identity and it's not
difficult once you understand what
you're doing and why you're doing it and
the more you combine all those different
branches of science and make it in a
simple way to understand if people
understand the what and the why the how
gets easier because you can assign
meaning to what you're doing and it
becomes instrumental so get a group of
people a thousand people 1500 people 2
000 people into a room
teach them that information whether
they're coming for wealth or health a
relationship a new career a mystical
experience get them all together
and teach them and measure what can take
place in one week period of time and I
assure you that's more than 75 percent
of the people that go through and go all
in and Retreat from their lives and
remove the same stimulation from their
environment and not be in the same
conditions and teach them that
information and give them numerous
opportunities to apply it and numerous
opportunities to get Beyond themselves
all you need is that first person that
stands on the stage and says hey I
walked in here with Parkinson's disease
I have no idea what happened but I'm not
trembling anymore and boy that last
thing just something clicked for me and
the person in the audience is watching
the four minute mile right in front of
them and going wow that guy looks like
he's not a vegan he doesn't look like
he's particularly in shape but his
Parkinson's went away and wow I mean if
he could do it I could do it and
somebody else changes their belief and
now that's a footprint and Consciousness
get enough people doing that
by the end of the week you're going to
see things we've seen blind people
seeing deaf people hearing that once not
twice people with Strokes for 10 years
lift their arms up again we've seen
people step out of wheelchairs people on
crutches drop their cracks I mean you
see
the body literally recalibrates to a new
mind and and they're not intentionally
trying to do anything they're just
becoming somebody else but the process
of overcoming
is the process of becoming and if you
teach people that formula and you get
just one or two people doing it it's
just going to become an infection and
it's gonna Wellness is gonna spread just
like disease I think it's a time in
history where it's not enough to know
it's a time in history to know how
and if you think about it um
most people live their life in a habit
they think the same thoughts they
perform the same actions they live by
the same emotions but they secretly
expect their life to change
but how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality and
your personality creates your personal
reality that's it so if you think sixty
to seventy thousand thoughts in one day
and ninety percent of those thoughts are
the same thoughts as the day before the
same thoughts always lead to the same
choices the same choices always lead to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
create the same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same emotions
and those same emotions then drive your
very same thoughts and so you get caught
in this kind of biological neurological
and Quantum fixated pattern
so then the hardest part about change
really in creating the life that you
want being defined by a vision of the
future instead of a memory of the past
is not making the same choices you did
the day before and the moment you do
that you step into the unknown now you
and I have been conditioned and
hypnotized into believing that the
unknown is some scary place but when you
begin to realize the unknown is the
perfect place to create from that void
of unpredictability that uncertainty
that unfamiliarity is really the quantum
place of uncertainty where all
manifestations come from so when you and
I become comfortable living in that
unknown place I think then that we begin
to manifest the things we want in our
lives so for me personally
I want to execute and be defined by a
vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past so most people's
brains are organized to reflect
everything they know in their life their
brain is a record of the past
and if you feel the same way every
single day and feelings and emotions are
the end product of past experiences it
means number one nothing new is
happening in your life and number two
those emotions are keeping you anchored
to the past if thoughts are the language
of the brain and feelings are the
language of the body and how you think
and how you feel creates a state of
being most people are literally
biologically neurologically chemically
genetically and even Quantum wise
connected to a past so then the question
is the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future that you
can't see or experience with your senses
yet but you've thought about enough
times in your mind that your brain has
literally changed to look like the
experience has already occurred now the
latest research in neuroscience and
neuroplasticity tells us we can change
our brain to look like the event has
already occurred and can we begin to
emotionally Embrace a future reality
that's a potential in the quantum field
and begin to emotionally embrace it to
such agree that we fall in love with
that future reality that our bodies Our
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and we're signaling new
genes in new ways to change our body to
look like the experience has already
occurred in preparation for the event
now think about this so making our inner
World more real than the outer world
right but not only that
you have to then understand that when
you truly do this properly you're not
waiting for your healing to feel whole
you're not waiting for your success to
feel empowered you're not waiting for
your wealth to feel abundant you're not
waiting for your new relationship to
feel love you're not waiting for the
mystical moment to feel awe that's the
old model of reality of cause and effect
waiting for something outside of you to
change how you feel inside of you and
when you feel better inside and you pay
attention to whoever whatever caused
that that's that's cause and effect and
when you begin to make the correlation
between what changed you from outside
and inside you create an associate of
memory
the quantum model of reality begins to
say then you have to teach your body
emotionally how that future is going to
feel like before it's made manifest in
other words you have to feel awe in
order for the mystical moment to happen
you have to feel a abundance before your
wealth can occur you have to feel in
love with life before your new
relationship happens and so we're not
defining Reality by our senses because
we're not waiting then for anything
outside of us to change how we feel
inside of us so if there's physical
evidence in your brain and body to look
like the experience has already occurred
physical evidence
because the epigenetic model of reality
says you can change your body by thought
alone you and neuroplasticity says you
can change your brain by thought alone
so if there's physical evidence to look
like the experience has already occurred
well relax because the experience is
going to find you and it's going to come
in a way that you least expect the
survival emotions the emotions that are
derived from the hormones of stress are
very addictive
anger is addictive fear is addictive
sadness is addictive resentment is
addictive competition is addictive
frustration is addictive all of those
emotions that are derived from the
hormones of stress give the brain and
body A Rush of energy so if an addiction
is something you can't stop and you
happen to have a friend or a family
member who's walking around suffering
every single day of their life and you
say to them why don't you stop or you
you're in the middle of an angry
experience and I say to you Michael why
don't you just stop being angry if you
can't stop
you can't stop that that on some level
you're addicted because an addiction is
something you can't stop so when people
start to understand oh my God I'm
addicted to my own frustration I'm
addicted to my own suffering I'm
addicted to my own guilt all of a sudden
they start becoming conscious of what
they're doing to their brain and body
show them how those very chemicals down
regulate genes to create disease
and then get them beyond that by doing
meditation that's the moment then all of
a sudden they begin to be greater than
their biology and we've measured this
thousands of times in people and it's
without a doubt I can say this from
every single cell in my being that a
person is at their absolute best when
they get Beyond themselves that's the
bottom line seventy percent of the time
people live in by the hormones are
stress whether they know it or not
they're always anticipating the future
based on the past they're always having
their attention on objects and people
and things and places in the world
because that's where the danger is the
chemicals are jacking up their body so
their attention is on their body so they
think based on their own experience that
they're their body but they're not they
believe that they're their identity
that's connected to relationships of
people and things and places in their
life but they're not then when people
start to live on autopilot and they get
out of bed the same way and they brush
their teeth at the same hand and they do
all the same things every single day and
they've been doing that for 20 or 30
years for the most part then their
bodies on autopilot it's in a
predictable future based on what it's
done in the past so very few people are
in the present moment so then they're
locked into a line of time a linear line
of time where their future and their
past seem to be exactly the same so no
not a lot of people are present or in
the present moment and if you're not in
the present moment I assert that you're
running some type of program which means
you're not present the body's already
programmed to be in the future in the
past so then
in an elegant moment of meditation and
we've we can predict this now on a brain
scan there comes a moment where a person
forgets about their body
they forget they're they're so involved
in their inner world that there is
nobody
they forget that they are an identity
they're not paying attention to the
people they know and the places they go
and the things they have to do or the
things they own they become no one they
become no thing they go to nowhere and
they forget about their appointments in
their past and they become no time and
that is the moment they become pure
Consciousness that is the moment that
they begin to disconnect from their
biology and who you are to answer that
question is a Consciousness that's
manipulating the brain and body to
produce different levels of mind
and only when you are pure consciousness
can you begin to change your body
only when you are beyond your body can
you heal your body you can't the body
can't heal the body you have to get
beyond your body to heal your body in
order for you to create some new
experience in your life you got to get
beyond the problems in your life in
order for you to create some new future
event in some future time you got to get
Beyond predictable linear time and so if
you're going to heal your body by
thought alone if you're going to create
some experience in your life by thought
alone if you are going to create some
new event in your future by thought
alone then you have to become thought
alone and that is the moment when you
become pure Consciousness where you are
nobody no one no thing nowhere in no
time that is the moment
that you're no longer constrained by
those laws that is the moment your
Consciousness free will the subjective
human consciousness merges with the
quantum field the objective Universal
Consciousness and when they come
together and you come back to awareness
you take a piece of it with you and you
become more like it you become more
willful it has an amazing will you
become more mindful it has an infinite
mind become more conscious it has a
great Consciousness you become more
loving it's a it's a love it's a lover
of life you become more Giver giving
it's a giver of life it's it's nature
becomes your nature and so teaching
people how to do that uh is the art so
then when you understand that you we we
we now know that there are certain ways
to do that that help people get there
faster according to the psychological
and scientific model
the majority of people in their waking
day in a normal day spend about 70
percent of their time living in stress
and living in stress is living in
survival
and the actual definition of stress
stress is when your body's knocked out
of homeostasis
stress is when your body's not that of
balance
the stress response is what your body
innately does to return itself back to
order you have three types of stress you
have physical stress like trauma
injuries accidents Falls you have
chemical stress like bacteria viruses
blood sugar levels heavy metals and
Foods hangovers whatever
and you have emotional stress like
traffic jams internet connections second
mortgages single parenting 401ks family
tragedies all of those things knock the
brain and body out of balance
now all organisms in nature can adapt to
short-term stress
pack of coyotes chases a deer in the in
the forest the deer outruns the coyotes
the stress is over the theory turns back
to homeostasis and it grazes again the
event is over when the deer perceives a
threat in its external environment it
turns on a primitive nervous system
called the fight-or-flight nervous
system
and that autonomic nervous system that
sympathetic nervous system begins to
mobilize enormous amounts of energy for
some threat in the external environment
now the year has all its physiology
changed all the blood is sent to the
extremities heart rate increases
respiratory rate rate increases pupils
dilate dilate the 1300 chemicals that
are created in a matter of seconds is to
cause the deer to survive in some
difficult condition
now
human beings have the same mechanisms
and when we perceive a threat in our
external environment like a lion we are
going to run or fight or freeze
but if you've had problems with your
co-worker
or you've had a very difficult
experience with your mother-in-law
the moment you perceive your
mother-in-law or your co-worker you and
you have a past experience with them
you're going to turn on the same
primitive nervous system
just like you were being chased by a
lion so what was once highly adaptive
now becomes very maladaptive because
when you're mobilizing all of that
energy
you are going to operate in very
predictable ways you're going to be an
amped up animal with a big memory bank
so that your blood flow is going to go
to the hind brain and away from the
forebrain which means you're going to
react instead of think
rationalize
but human beings the privilege of being
a human being is that we can make
thought more real than anything else
that's the privilege
so then you can begin to forecast
some future worst case scenario
and you can attend to that thought to
the exclusion of everything else
and you can focus on it to such a degree
that you will begin to anticipate the
event and produce the same chemicals as
if you're in that experience and you're
knocking your brain and body out of
balance just by thought alone
you can begin to unfold some past bitter
memory that's tattooed in the recesses
of your gray matter and like magic you
can bring it to life and in that moment
it's real and you will produce the same
chemistry in your brain and body as if
that event occurred and your body is the
unconscious mind is literally living
that experience
so then when we're living by the
hormones of stress and you turn on that
stress response and you can't turn it
off now you're headed for some disease
because no organism in nature can
tolerate living in emergency mode for
extended periods of time so if 70 of the
time a person's living in survival
living in stress in survival what we do
in order to survive
as we are going to select the worst case
scenario
and we are going to begin to plan our
behaviors and our emotions in that
experience because anything less than
the worst case scenario means we have
better chances of survival so we plan
for the worst we emotionally embrace it
and anything less means we can survive
so out of the infinite Potentials in the
quantum field
anxiety really represents a poor
imagination but it's highly adaptive if
it's if you're living in survival
because you got to get ready for that so
seventy percent of the time people are
selecting the worst case event in their
life and emotionally embracing it and
they're they're programming their
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny and turns out if you
keep doing that and you create the
emotions of fear and worry and anxiety
and you do that for 10 years or five
years or three years your body is going
to unconsciously become programmed to
fear and it's going to have a panic
attack without you try as you may with
your conscious mind to control it you've
programmed it subconsciously and now the
body as the mind is running the show
so
the hormones of stress
create the emotions of anger
of aggression of hostility of violence
of frustration of hatred of fear of
anxiety of guilt of Shame of
hopelessness of powerlessness depression
those are all chemicals that are derived
from the hormones of stress and when we
live by the hormones of stress we become
very selfish why because when you're in
survival you've got to take care of the
self your attention is on your body
right your attention is on your external
environment there's Predators out there
the the rush of adrenaline causes the
senses to become heightened and you're a
materialist and you're trying to predict
the future because there's better
chances of survival if you can predict
the future based on the past when that
occurs then over time
the body begins to break down because
it's a scientific fact
that the hormones of stress down
regulate genes to create disease in the
long term
so if you can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone
and the hormones of stress can make you
sick
then your thoughts can literally make
you sick so the question is if your
thoughts can make you sick
is it possible then that your thoughts
can make you well most people number one
they get up in the morning and the first
thing they do is they think about the
problems in their life and those
problems are memories from the past so
the moment they think about their
problems they're thinking in the past
right every one of those problems has an
emotion attached to them so they start
feeling unhappy or unworthy or whatever
and how you think and how you feel is
your state of being so most people's
entire state of beings in the past when
they start today so within the familiar
past they're going to live in a
predictable future right so they get up
and they check their cell phone they
check for text their WhatsApp or
Facebook they post something on Facebook
they tweet they Twitter they check the
news then they go to the bathroom get a
cup of coffee take a shower get dressed
check bar emails drive to work the same
way do the same thing so for the program
they've actually lost their free will to
the program wow so if you start your day
and you start your day with this simple
question what is the greatest ideal of
myself that I can be today you ask
yourself that question now listen your
body's going to go like well we gotta
get a cup of coffee
and you gotta go body
you're not the mind I'm the mind right
now you're gonna sit here I'm gonna feed
you you're gonna get your coffee you're
gonna do all those things but right now
this is my time you're gonna obey me
right so now the body's no longer the
mind you're the mind and so when it
wants to get up and you become aware of
it and we turn back to the present
moment every time you do that's a
victory when you're changing some aspect
of yourself so then
ask yourself I do this all the time
write down four thoughts that you're
going to stay conscious of the whole day
I can't it's too hard you'd be surprised
the moment you become conscious of what
those thoughts are how unconscious
you've been to them all day you know for
weeks on end write down what you speak
how you speak four things you want to
change how you act how do you how do you
act if you complain you blame you make
excuses you feel sorry for yourself
that's a victim Consciousness what
emotions do you live by is it possible
that you're so used to living by guilt
you don't even know it's guilt it just
feels like you you allow your energy to
drop become conscious of those states of
mind and body and review them and say
this is the old self then say what
thoughts do I want to fire and wire in
my brain and start firing and wiring and
start feeling it what behaviors will I
demonstrate today what choices will I
make one day one lifetime just like you
did rehearse them rehearse the whole
entire thing begin to install the
neurological Hardware in your brain and
if you keep installing it the hardware
is going to become a software program
and you start thinking and acting that
way and then here's the tough part can
you teach your body emotionally
what your future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest and don't get
up until you feel that way I think the
first thing is to learn every time you
learn you make new Connections in your
brain and learning is making those
connections and I was joking with my
staff this week I said nobody reads
anymore nobody reads nobody reads
anything learn information why because
we found out
that in our events if you can be present
and not look at your cell phone or not
talk about your past but be present with
the content and I can combine quantum
physics with Neuroscience with
neuroendocrinology with
psychoneuroimmunology Mind Body
Connection epigenetics electromagnetism
you can really get it like you can give
me the nod and then I say okay you I
looking at an audience of 1500 600
people okay well turn to the person next
to you and teach it back to them if you
can't explain that um
it's not wired in your brain and you'll
doubt that it's possible and you'll do
something differently okay if you can
explain it then you're causing your
brain to Fire and new sequences and new
patterns and new combinations whenever
you make your brain work differently
you're changing your mind why
because mind is the brain in action so
you keep reminding yourself of this now
this it's easier to forget this than
remember it you know it takes practice
it really you can't get it in one bite
it's a learning process right so now
you're installing the neurological
Hardware in your brain in preparation
for the experience so knowledge is the
precursor to the experience right
without the knowledge and the
information it's conjecturous right so
the more you understand the what in the
terms of what you're doing and the why
you're doing it the application the
Practical aspect the how becomes
exciting like oh I'm going to get it as
an example you can take someone and
throw them in an ice bath
we have no knowledge of ice but what
that can do and then because they have
no knowledge the ice path is actually
going to is going to cost them harm
right right you take that person you can
teach them a few things and put them in
an ice bath and actually be instrumental
actually gain value from it well the
prefrontal cortex the one that said now
you got to make this you got to make
this valuable you can take a person
and you can you can put them in an
environment and they can perceive the
environment as a problem and you can
measure their autonomic response and
it'll weaken their autonomic response
you can take that person and have them
perceive it as a challenge and it'll
actually strengthen their autonomic
response okay so now what's the what's
what's the reason behind this well you
gotta you gotta put as much tension on
your inner world
of how you're thinking and how you're
feeling and how you're going to behave
as much as your outer world of
three-dimensional reality and meditation
is just a way to say okay let me get my
brain and body right I'm going to
present Ed mylett to the world today I
got one lifetime one groundhog day one
day
I just want something different
something unusual something mystical
some sign from the universe that I
created and I wanted to come in a way
that I would never think of that would
be the unknown because if I can predict
it it's the known okay let me before I
get up and grab my phone
and do all my things and get plugged
back into my Known World let me just say
okay who do I no longer want to be I
want to become so conscious that I won't
go unconscious again the fundamental
question is how many times
am I going to forget until I stop
forgetting and start remembering that is
the moment there's nothing mystical
about this
this is the work
and then you're going to say okay who do
I want to be when I open my eyes okay
let me think about this how would
greatness left we I don't know read a
book on greatness read a book on Nelson
Mandela you want to be wealthy read
about wealthy people and you're going to
see that they didn't just make their
wealth they lost a ton of money and
failed them a million times it was and
that's reality okay well let's what what
were the qualities they were they had
perseverance they had determination they
let they cut their losses they forgave
they forgot about it they went on okay
so how am I going to behave let me
rehearse how I'm going to behave
I'm gonna do me take my time I have I
have plenty of time to do let me just
behave let me think about how I'm going
to behave differently in this situation
how am I going to change my emotional
response when did I fall from grace
yesterday and went back to my old self
let me just I'll set up I'll set an
alarm on my phone every three hours I'm
gonna just gonna go off and I'm gonna
take a moment and get back into the
feelings of my future okay
if I can do that over and over again
well what what do you think could happen
in my life as a result of it so
knowledge being the Forerunner the
application simple stuff simple stuff
practice hard coherence there's plenty
of stuff that we can you know we can
talk about practice brain coherence it's
we know we know I asked the brain
scientists what percentage of people at
the end of a week-long event uh what
percentage of people will have their
brains changed for the better they said
100 100 one week fully immersed in into
the experience you practice it every day
now
you can do it once or twice and say why
isn't my bank account full you know what
I'm going to tell you you're not that
good yeah that's the only reason why if
you were that good it would happen
you're not that good so show up again
and show up again and keep showing up
and I just was talking to a staff member
today the universe only gives us what we
think we're worthy of receiving right so
then people who show up for themselves
every day I believe they're worthy they
they start feeling pretty damn worthy
like hey they're like I'm worthy for
this not like an entitlement way like
something or are they just like I'm I'm
really I'm real I feel like it's gonna
happen I'm worthy for it I learned a lot
about expectation when I was studying uh
the placebo uh you know it's amazing how
you can give someone a sugar pill or a
saline injection or perform some false
surgery or treatment
and a certain percentage of those people
will accept believe and surrender to the
thought
that it's actually the truth without
analyzing it that they're getting an
actual real substance and their body
begins to manufacture the very Pharmacy
of chemicals
that causes them to heal by thought
alone so the question is is it the you
know inert exogenous substance that's
doing the healing or is it the body's
innate capacity to heal so so everybody
has been conditioned to a certain degree
whether we like it or not to rely on
something outside of us
to change our inner State and and and so
when a person's given a pill and it's
and it's blue on one side and red on the
other and they take it and they notice a
change in their internal State my pain
has gone away uh I'm sleeping better
whatever it is
and when they notice that change in
their internal State they pay attention
to what caused it and they start to
associate and condition so well if you
keep doing that over and over again
uh that pill uh becomes a symbol of them
to change their physiology so if you
take that pill and you replace it with
something that's a nerd and they see
that pill based on conditioning when
they take that pill conditioning based
on the past they begin to expect
that outcome to happen again and the
expectation of the outcome is simply
marrying a a possibility an intention a
vision of a future outcome a new
possibility in the quantum field
and if the doctor's enthusiastic and you
name the substance something that you
can't pronounce and you charge a lot of
money for it and you use a name that
rhymes with something that could
actually you could associate as a known
uh you know Niagara and Viagra there's a
strong correlation it's a lot of flow
and and so people are conditioned to
expect an outcome so
when they start to expect the outcome
the marrying of that clear intention if
the person is optimistic if the person
is enthusiastic if the person is uh uh
grateful for the outcome a combination
of that clear intention combined with
the elevated emotion
begins to change the body's physiology
for them to manufacture their own
Pharmacy of antidepressants their own
Pharmacy of morphines are pain relievers
their own Pharmacy of dopamine by
thought alone so the question is do you
need the exogenous substance to change
your state of being or can you change
your state of being by thought alone
and by the same means if you give a
person a prognosis and you tell them
that in the chemotherapy treatments you
are going to get really nauseous and
sick they've done research on this fifty
percent of the people on their Drive
to the chemotherapy treatment start to
get nauseous in anticipation of the
event taking place so the question is
can 50 of the people get well on their
drive to work or they're on their drive
to their doctor and anticipation in
anticipation of getting the right
treatment in your studies with the power
of aid
if the person can assign meaning
to the value of what they're doing and
they can see oh my God energy can
actually inform matter okay that sounds
like something that makes sense give me
the quantum understanding and you get a
collective group of people and we're
discovering that Collective networks of
Observers
determine reality and you can get them
in a very specific State and the person
who's receiving the healing understands
the the value of what's taking place
the expectation of what's about to
happen if they're in a state of
gratitude it's kind of an interesting
thing gratitude when we receive
something when we've just received
something favoritable when something's
happening to us that we really enjoy or
something just happened to us that
surprises us we feel gratitude so the
emotional signature of gratitude is
something's happening to us or something
favorable just happened to it it is the
ultimate state that we receive in so if
the person's in that state of gratitude
then it makes sense then they're more
susceptible to information because we
accept believe and surrender to
information equal to our emotional state
so that can actually program the
autonomic nervous system to begin to
physiologically change and that's
exactly what Pavlov did with the
salivating dogs just ring the bell and
feed them a meal and after a while the
anticipation
of the event actually causes them to
change their body's physiology their
autonomic nervous system begins to
change as if they're actually in the
process of eating the meal the
anticipation is preparing for the event
ahead of time and we can use that to so
many degrees in our favor the hormones
of stress push the genetic buttons that
create disease if you can turn on the
stress response just by thought alone
your thoughts could make you sick and if
your thoughts could make you sick is it
possible that your thoughts could make
you well so they began to realize that
oh my God the repetition of thinking and
feeling and feeling and thinking caused
me to feel guilt and I don't even know
it's guilt it just feels like me it's
just I'm used to the same chemical
continuity now the moment they decided
to change anytime you decide to change
and change anything about yourself get
ready because it's going to feel
uncomfortable It's Gonna Hurt you're
going to leave The Gnome yeah you're
gonna leave the familiar and you're
gonna step into the unknown even if the
familiar is uncomfortable and painful
right you still can be painful leaving
the pain right because some people are
super happy being unhappy right so then
they would rather cling to their
suffering than take a chance and
possibility so these people said I
really have nothing to lose right
so then they said I'm willing to be
uncomfortable and be in the unknown and
it turns out that's the perfect place to
create from so when the body is
conditioned to become the mind then to
change is to be greater than the body
right because we become greater than the
body well that's a whole nother
conversation but let me finish this okay
so the third thing they said was
okay so now that I know that I got to
break the habit of being myself and I
can't mismanage my thoughts and feelings
I got to change how I act I got to watch
how I speak I gotta become conscious of
how unconscious I am because 95 percent
of Who We Are by the time we're 35 years
old it's a set of memorized behaviors
like a computer program emotional
reactions unconscious beliefs and
perceptions so the first step to change
is to become conscious of how you think
to notice how you act to pay attention
to how you feel and the act of observing
those states of Mind and Body separates
you from that program now you're you're
you're the Consciousness observing that
program it turns out the more conscious
you become of how unconscious you are
you know lighting a match in a dark
place
that first step creates enormous amounts
of Chaos in the brain and body and it's
disturbing so people just go back to the
same addiction the same emotion the same
problem just feels better no that feels
familiar so they said okay now I'm not
going to change I gotta reinvent myself
now this is really important because
they started sitting down and thinking
Okay who in history do I admire we're
great people role models that I could
follow what are the qualities and
characteristics that they have how am I
going to change you know these are what
we call frontal lobe questions the
creative center of the brain switches on
an emotional Center settles down
so then they started thinking
I have to be in a new life if I was
really going to heal what would I have
to change about myself
now there's this interesting phenomenon
that if you close your eyes and you
begin to think about doing something
you're an athlete you understand this if
you're a background in football and you
are running a pattern or you are doing
something you would rehearse it in your
mind turns out
that the act of mentally rehearsing
something when you're truly present
your brain does not know the difference
between what's going on out there and
what's going on in here in fact your
brain will begin to look like you've
been doing it for the last five days and
you've never run the course so now your
brain is no longer a record of the past
because typically it is now it's a map
to the Future so now you're priming your
brain so that became the very platform
you know experiments with piano players
you know you take a group of people that
never played the piano before you divide
them into two different categories I
think one group of people you teach them
one-handed scales and chords you do a
brain scan on them they come in practice
for two hours a day for five days at the
end of five days if you rescan the brain
they grow new circuits on the opposite
side of the brain nothing magical there
you learn something new learning's
making new connections get some
instruction you get instruction you get
your body involved get your body
involved you're gonna have an experience
experience in which is the brain pay
attention to what you're doing you got
to pay attention and repeat it firing
and wiring here into assemble new
circuits you can take the other group of
people have them come for two hours a
day for five days do a brain scan before
the brain scan after have them close
their eyes and mentally rehearse playing
those scales and chords
at the end of five days they'll grow the
same amount of circuits and their brain
as the people who actually physically
demonstrated the action what does that
mean it means not only they change their
brain by thinking differently but their
brain looks like they've been playing
the piano for five days now set them in
front of a piano never play the piano
before they'll play those scales and
chords because their brain is wired to
play it so now the act of rehearsing who
they're going to be
what are the qualities I'm beginning to
get in this creative state began to lay
down the circuits of a new personality
and a new personality is connected to a
new personal reality so the next
question is does that change the body
take a group of men have them do
one-handed
curls in their mind and bring an
emotional component like stronger harder
more intense one hour a day for two
weeks at the end of two weeks 13.5
increase in muscle strength never lifted
away now their body is changing by
thought a lot so these people began to
reprogram their brain and body
and all of a sudden they began to act
differently why because they installed
the circuits they began to think
differently of course they began to feel
differently they they were no longer
feeling pain they're actually liking
themselves right so that if they're
living by a different emotion and
they're they're feeling an elevated
emotion before their healing before they
were healed they're not waiting for
their healing to feel Joy and gratitude
they're feeling gratitude and joy now
their bodies believing that it's healed
because the body's feeling the emotion
ahead of the experience if the
environment signals the Gene and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is emotion you're signaling
the gene ahead of the environment and
what do genes do genes make proteins or
what are proteins responsible the
structure and function of the body now
you're literally becoming somebody else
and now you're turning down the genes
for a disease and you're turning up
these other genes so
I started to realize that this
reinvention process is exactly what
we've always done it's just that we get
complacent in certain areas of our life
and we stop let's demystify the present
moment okay people wake up in the
morning and they they think about their
problems and those problems or memories
that are etched in their brain they're
connected to certain people and objects
at certain times and places the moment
they wake up in the morning and they
start thinking of their problems they're
thinking in the past
okay now every one of those problems has
an emotion associated with it so when
they feel unhappy when they feel bitter
when they feel fearful now their bodies
in the past thoughts are the language of
the brain feelings of the language of
the body thought and a feeling image and
emotion stimulus and response you're
conditioning the body to be the mind of
that emotion subconsciously now the body
is believing it's living in the same
past experience 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days a year why because
the body's so objective it doesn't know
the difference between the real life
experience that's creating that emotion
and the emotion that person is creating
by thought alone important the body
doesn't know that difference and so what
would the environment signals the gene
that's epigenetics the end product from
an experience in the environment is an
emotion the person's signaling the same
genes in the same way and genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of your
body and the expression of proteins as
an expression of life and now the person
is actually headed for a genetic Destiny
and when people labor
for the present moment
and they take their attention off of
their body off of all the people in
their life all of the objects they own
their cell phone their computer their
car their house they're no longer
identifying with where they're sitting
where they need to be where they live
where they've lived in the past where
they need to go and they're not thinking
about the predictable future of the
familiar past
they're dissociating from everything
physical and material everything known
that is the exact moment we call getting
Beyond yourself okay now
when we're in that place then at the
beginning it's uncomfortable because
work survival is the unknown you better
chances of survival and running from the
unknown but that unknown is the perfect
place to create from so in the process
no different than any rehab in our first
two days of our event really people are
they're basically they're basically
rehabbing from their emotional states
and their habits and they're sitting in
the presence of that discomfort right
and the discomfort is because the body
is leaving the known but but but
if the body has been conditioned to be
the mind the moment you take it outside
of its familiar territory it's going to
start telling you Ed why don't you quit
you know you're not really good at this
you know you're more of a physical
person you don't really want to do this
you're not very this or very fat and
most people just get up on there do
their meditation they believe that
thought as if it's true now the question
is what's on the other side of that
thought can you sit there long enough
till that's no longer the thought you
accept believe and surrender to well
then wow the next question inside of
that thought what is the other what's on
the other side of that familiar emotion
can I sit and work with my body and
settle it down stay
you stay I'm gonna feed you you're not
gonna die from this your bladder's not
going to explode you're not gonna go
crazy and you work with catching those
thoughts it's called metacognition if
you're in that 95 of programming where
you're unconscious
and the first step to change is becoming
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
you're so conscious that you would never
go unconscious or let that thought slip
by you unnoticed I want to understand so
you're saying the awareness of the
thought being conscious of the thought
has it somehow lose its power over you
exactly exactly because just because you
have a thought doesn't mean it's true
and if you're left alone to yourself
you'll start believing every thought you
think and that's the problem so then the
majority of people's thoughts then are
based on what they perceive about
themselves from their past or their life
right and if you catch yourself
complaining and blaming and making
excuses and judging someone else and you
say I want to be a happy person well a
happy person would never do that would
make them unhappy if you notice that
you've been feeling guilty for the last
20 years you didn't know it was guilt
because it just felt like you and you
want to feel Joy well if you can feel
Joy it should tell us volumes about what
you've been practicing doing right so
then most people give up because
they they don't know that there's
anything on the other side of it so then
the next question is
what thoughts do you want to fire and
wire in your brain well and with
attention and with intention
if you keep practicing firing wiring
those thoughts you start installing
Hardware do it enough times and it
becomes like a software program and now
that's the new voice you program in your
head that said I can do this I believe
in myself and you've created to an
extent a new personality which can
create a new personal reality now here
we go so then the next question is how
am I going to behave with my kids today
how am I going to be with my wife I'm
going to be with my partner I'm going to
be at work I might be on my zoom calls
I'm going to be by myself how am I going
to what what does greatness look like
what is what would love do today now it
turns out that if you close your eyes
and you start imagining doing that if
you rehearse how you're going to be in
those certain situations
the evidence without a doubt shows that
your brain will start to look like
through the mental rehearsal of the act
that you've already done it now you've
installed the hardware keep doing it it
becomes a software program and you'll
start acting like a happy person no
magic there if you don't have the
circuits you can't do it so the
rehearsal then
is actually changing the brain just by
thinking differently the brain looks
like the experience has already happened
now you have Hardware to use do it
enough times you get good at it becomes
more automatic now here's the hard part
can I teach my body emotionally
what my future will feel like before it
happens now this is really important
because there's a pandemic going on in
the world that has nothing to do with a
virus that has everything to do with
people's attention span and learning
people need a rush of dopamine in order
to catch their attention or a rush of
adrenaline to learn and so that they're
they're dependent on their outer
environment to regulate their emotional
state now this is different now now I'm
going to say to you
get in that beautiful heart of yours and
I want you to feel gratitude for the
event before it occurs well I can't feel
it because it hasn't happened yet yeah
that's the conditioning that's the
hypnosis anxiety is doing this living in
the survival when you're living in
survival I'll tell you this when the
survival Gene is activated out of the
infinite Potentials in the quantum field
you'll always choose the worst case
scenario why because if you're in
survival and you're preparing for the
worst there's always better chances of
surviving if anything less happens so
people are always selecting the worst
thing in their mind and they begin to
emotionally Embrace that future before
it happens thought and emotion you start
conditioning so you're conditioning the
body to become the mind of fear you keep
doing that enough times once the body
becomes the mind it's a subconscious
program a person has a panic attack try
as you made a control with your
conscious mind you can't you programmed
it subconsciously now you worry about
the next panic attack and now as you
start worrying about the next panic
attack it's the vigilance that creates
the next one wow now here's what's
happening in our work
people who are self-regulating and
creating these elevated States we have
we have heart scans of them sustaining
hard coherence for a whole hour during a
meditation then at the end of the day
they're still wearing the monitor it's
eight o'clock at night they're not even
in a meditation and for a whole entire
hour they're in hard coherence we say to
the woman uh what's going on here she
said I have no idea I was just getting
ready for bed and all of a sudden my
heart just swelled up it was so intense
I had to lay on my back and surrender to
love WoW instead of surrendering to fear
she had a spontaneous love attack
instead of a spontaneous panic attack
now I would call that the natural state
of being so then
if you're living by those elevated
States and you know how to feel that
emotion of your future before it happens
you're less likely to wait for it to
happen because you'll feel like it
already happened you'll less likely try
to control it you'll know that the
moment you lose the feeling you just
disconnected and you're going to make
your way back when you get good at it no
person no thing no experience can take
it away from you now you're empowered
and if you understand the laws of how
creation happens then you're less likely
to compete and rush to get what you want
you're going to know that it's going to
come to you and now that's the new model
of how we create we had a guy that came
in a wheelchair an event we did recently
it came in that Throne he walked from he
had ALS he walked from the back of the
room all the way to the stage walked up
the stairs out of that wheelchair on his
own I asked him he said I just I just
have to work on staying in this
emotional state because the longer I
stay there the more I'm noticing that my
body's responding he's not saying why am
I why am I not healed he understands
that the only way he can actually heal
is to change him right and so now it
becomes very practical right it becomes
very practical I think it's important
that practical part of it I think
sometimes people think they're
disqualified if they can't explain
something they do well let me tell you
one of the interesting things on the
show many of the people that do things
exceptionally well that have been on my
show athletes or entertainers
really don't do a very good job of
explaining it yeah they embody it and I
think sometimes someone listens to
somebody like you who can explain this
and think that they're disqualified from
becoming good if they can't explain how
they're doing it but the truth is it's a
repeated experience that becomes
familiar for them without the need to
express how they're doing it right right
and for me right this is your this is
your life is teaching people to do this
and giving them the tools but for the
vast majority of people it's it's
creating the experience a lot of
everybody everybody has done this at
least once in their life what did they
did they sat down and they said what
would it be like to be happy what would
it be like to be healthy what would it
be like to have a new life what would we
like to be in love and they ask the
question instead of getting on their
cell phone and texting somewhere posting
they actually sat there and they
actually said let me answer the question
yeah let me get uncomfortable here and
what is it that I truly want what would
I have to change about myself to be
healthy to be happy to be well
successful what are my bad habits they
get busy writing down
all the the the choices they want to
make all the things they want to do they
start writing down all their goals all
their experiences and every goal or
experience that I write down in their
future there's an emotion they get
inspired they get optimistic they get
grateful they get energized and those
emotions fuel more thoughts and now
they're they're they're actually
changing their biology and then they do
something really really really really
really important
they start looking at the thoughts that
they no longer want to think they write
them down I can't it's too hard I'll
start tomorrow I don't feel good I'm
doing uh they start looking at the
choices they're going to have to stop
making and when they they understand
when they stop making those choices it's
going to be uncomfortable that's the
hardest part about change they start
thinking about the things they have to
stop doing I gotta get off the couch I
got to stop watching this I gotta stop
over reading whatever it is and then
we've all done this
and there comes a moment where you start
noticing that like you start saying hey
I believe this is this is actually going
to happen right and that's when you take
the foot off the gas pedal and you start
really realizing wow I was the resource
of actually making this happen and that
I changed yeah I changed in the process
so
the the exciting part about it you talk
people who created wealth who talk to
people who created relationships that
are talk to people who have created
Health they'll tell you my disease
my poverty was my greatest teacher my
past was my greatest teacher they looked
back at their past and now there's no
longer an emotion associated with it the
memory without the emotional charges
wisdom now you get to go to the Future
you get to create whatever your free
willed you you could be anybody you want
to be in the process I think you know
one of the most important things is it's
so much easier to forget this
information than to remember even me you
know I have to say to myself okay Joe
dispenza what do you know and take a
moment and just set down my cell phone
and disconnect from everything and
really have a thought like
and keep reconstructing the model in my
mind it's so important to do that
because if we understand the what and
the why and the how it gets easier then
we assign more meaning and more belief
and more intention behind it and
and if you have to say okay
okay if I'm living by these emotions
that are familiar to me and I'm
signaling the same genes in the same way
okay now I have to be conscious of not
feeling that way and you have to make a
different choice and the hardest part
about changes stop making the same
choices you did the day before because
the moment he decided to do something
differently and make new Choice it's
going to be uncomfortable you're going
to leave the known familiar world of the
familiar emotions and thoughts and
behaviors
the body is the unconscious mind is
going to want to return back to what it
knows because we trained it that way so
it's a retraining process so if the
person says okay if I can marry a clear
intention I gotta work on getting my
brain more coherent okay they got that
in the formula that'll be a good signal
out if I could slow my brain waves down
I can learn how to do that I can get
beyond my thinking I'm a little combined
I can enter the operating system of my
autonomic nervous system program that
okay if I can combine it with an
elevated emotion really practice trading
that that suffering or that pain for
something else yeah it may take me a
little bit to feel that emotion but I
think if I keep working at it I'll begin
to change my emotional state when I feel
that emotional state I'm not going to be
thinking about the past I'm going to be
thinking about the future so so the
thought and the feeling the stimulus in
response the image and the emotion is
conditioning body emotionally into the
future so the person says okay he said
or I read or someone else said the
environment signals the gene okay let me
write that down environment signals the
gene okay I gotta remember that
the end product of an experience in the
environment is the emotion okay
um if I'm feeling gratitude
and gratitudes emotional signature means
I've just received something favorable
or something wonderful just happened to
me
if I can feel the emotion of gratitude
before the event occurs
then my body would be so objective that
it's living in that future I would begin
to change my gene expression and the
stronger the emotion I feel the more I'm
going to pay attention to the picture in
my mind that I'm going to be remembering
my future my brain and body are going to
look like the event has already occurred
before it happened and if genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of my
body and the expression of proteins is
the expression of life
then I'm going to keep signaling these
I'm going to keep knocking on the door
every day and I don't care if my life is
falling apart I'm not going to fall to
that familiar emotion I'm not going to
speak the same way I'm not going to
think the same way what thoughts do I
want to fire and wire in my brain and
with intention and attention I'm going
to keep reviewing them till it becomes
an automatic thought in my head like you
can
what how am I going to be today how am I
going to be with my family I'm going to
be in traffic I'm going to be with my
co-workers how am I going to be when I'm
alone
and you start rehearsing who you're
going to be the brain in the present
moment doesn't know the difference
between the outer world or the inner
world it's the brain what it's imagining
looks real and if we're present
the brain looks like you already did it
you're priming the brain it's no longer
on record of the past now you're it's a
map to the Future you're you're in place
keep practicing that rehearsal in your
mind it's going to become automatic and
you're going to start behaving like that
person then you said
can I teach my body emotionally what
this future feels like before it happens
if you could truly open your heart and
truly feel that elevated emotion if you
kept practicing that I promise you you
would feel more of that in your day and
less of the other place and meditation
means to become familiar with and how
you think how you act and how you feel
is your personality and your personality
creates your personal reality that's the
game right so when that occurs then it's
no longer about the past and what
happened to you and the story people
tell about that they're telling a story
of their future in fact they're more in
love with their future than they are
with their past they're they're they
believe in the future more than they
believe in their past and and I think
that when we believe in ourselves we
believe in possibilities and we believe
in possibilities we have to believe in
ourselves and showing up every day
means you must believe it's true when
you stop showing up then you don't
believe it's true any longer and and
enough people that have that kind of
conviction literally step into a new
body they step into a new a new life
they step into a new future and I I hope
um but that becomes the new normal
um and and you know research says that
Collective networks of observers
determine reality that's the latest
uh so we just got to make sure enough of
us are observing a different reality
from an elevated place of Union and
connection
that instead of Separation that's that
divides communities because of survival
and stress and that's a great way to
create polarity in the world and the
union of polarity takes place in the
heart and that's where it starts it
doesn't end there it just starts there
and when I see the heart and forming the
brain I saw two students that we grabbed
one was chasing a little child around a
one and a half year old child and he was
being challenged and the other guy was
working and Staffing and running around
and we got him in the chair and we said
okay let's let's get some brainer hard
coherence and you know we had 15 20
minutes to do with these guys and you
saw them way out of balance right it's
just way out of bounds and all of a
sudden here comes that low frequency in
the heart boom like a big drum boom
boom all of a sudden you see that low
frequency the energy in the heart that's
only indigenous to the heart itself
starts rising and then all of a sudden
you see it rise and then you see the
sympathetic nervous system rise with it
so now we know they're totally relaxed
and they're totally awake and aware the
sympathetic nervous isn't working for an
arousal when you see that kind of
connection and you see someone be able
to change that
a matter of moments my eyes say they
should be able to do that with their
eyes open at any moment it should be
such a skill and that's that's when we
we maintain our energy and our power a
good way to see that is that everybody
does it like everybody does that all the
time and they would here's the problem
all of that is fine the problem is is
that they're looking
through the lens of the past that
reality they're they're seeing they're
seeing their future through the lens of
the past they can't see possibility
because they can't think greater than
how they feel or feelings have become
the means of thinking and if you believe
that your thoughts have anything to do
with your destiny
then you're thinking in the past because
those emotions are driving your thoughts
and those emotions are the familiar
records of the past right so now so let
me just go one step further so so that
is
how people reaffirm themselves every
single day into a known identity and
let's just say the trauma or the
Betrayal or the loss or the shock or the
diagnosis was a profound moment that
created a strong emotion and that person
doesn't think that they have any control
of regulating and changing that emotion
because it's visceral it's somatic it's
real they feel it and that disturbance
that known they'd rather cling to that
pain they'd rather cling to that that
suffering the then to take a chance and
possibility to step outside the unknown
now the hardest part
I'm getting to time by the way the
hardest part about all of this
then is not making the same choices you
did the day before
so the moment you start to realize that
you complain that you blame that you
make excuses that you feel sorry for
yourself that you judge others that you
react emotionally to your spouse to your
ex to your co-worker to traffic the
moment you become conscious that you're
doing that and you say I'm gonna stop
well the body now the servant that is
now the mind that the servant is now the
master so now the body's clinging to the
known and you say okay I'm not going to
complain I'm not going to suffer anymore
you make a different choice and the body
says well wait a second
Jonathan you've been doing that for 30
years so you just what so the body
starts influencing the mind it starts
sending signals back to the brain and
says you can't do this it's too hard
start tomorrow it's your mother's fault
it's your culture's fault it's it's this
it's your past
and if you accept believe and surrender
to that thought
as if it's true without really having a
critical analysis of it it slips right
by your conscious mind and it causes you
to make the same choice that leads to
the same behavior that will reproduce
the same experience and there you are on
the couch feeling the same emotion and
you say this feels right well no that
feels familiar right so that's that's
how people live in the gnome they live
in the past so the predictable future
then is everybody gets up in routine and
they're on autopilot and they run
through a series of automatic behaviors
and if you do that enough time a habit
is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition do it enough times the body
will now know how to do it better than
the conscious mind it becomes implicit
right so now most people lose their free
will
to a set of programs and their body's
dragging them into a predictable future
based on what they did in the past and
that predictable future is the known as
well so if the familiar past is the
known and the predictable future is the
known there's only one place left
where the unknown exists and that's
really that sweet spot of the generous
present moment and when we truly can
become relaxed and dial down
the stress hormones that cause us to
live in survival that causes us to try
to anticipate the worst case scenario
that remembers the past if we can work
with the body and be greater than the
body
to be greater than our attention on
every element in our environment and
truly labor for the present moment that
unknown which has been conditioned to
the into the human being to be a scary
place because in survival you run from
the unknown if you can teach people to
actually relax into the present moment
and relax into that place that's the
unknown that's where possibility exists
and we all do it
and getting to that elegant moment then
time tends to alter you think only 10
minutes went by about an hour and a half
went by and where were you well as your
brain waves slow down in this process
when you're in like a thinking
analytical place like we are right now
we're in these great bearing wave
patterns called you understand beta
brainwith patterns but as you slow your
body down and starts moving to Alpha
time Alpha Waves tend to cause time to
seem a little bit more elongated when
you're in Theta which is when you're
half awake and you're half asleep and
you're relaxed and awake and that level
of theta time one moment seems really
long so you have an extension of time
and turns out that you can teach people
how to do this and when you do
their autonomic nervous system begins to
regulate back into order and stress is
autonomic dysregulation and all of a
sudden the person has a sense of energy
a sense of euphoria a sense of Freedom a
sense of clarity the brains we've
measured this their brains start firing
in more ordered more coherence that it
oscillates and synchronizes different
compartments of the brain or communities
of neurons are working together and you
start feeling more whole more like
yourself in the in the understanding of
yoga as an example
if you're truly really into the ACT
you forget about all your problems you
forget about all the things you got to
do you forget about what happened
yesterday breathing is away
to really change your brain waves as
we've studied this thousands of times
you slow your breathing down you slowing
your brain waves down you slow your
brain waves down you stopped analyzing
and thinking when do you over analyze
and overthink when you're in high high
high beta and when's that when you're
threatened when you feel danger when
when the stress hormones are running and
we've studied the brain when this
happens and when you're analyzing your
life within that disturbing emotion I
can guarantee you you're going to make
your brain worse in fact your thought of
the problem is actually producing the
very chemistry to arouse you further out
of balance so teaching people
how to find that generous present moment
and actually relax in the unknown and
dissociate from their body dissociate
from their environment and dissociate
from time the predictable future and the
familiar past causes them for some
reason to get a reboot in in their
nervous system and they think oh God it
must have been 10 minutes and oh my God
it was it was an hour and a half that
that to me
is taking all of your attention or
disinvesting all of your attention out
of this three-dimensional reality and
that's when the door to Creation or the
mystical moment really begins to happen
for people if you think about
the illusion of three-dimensional
reality and and this hologram that were
fooled into our senses into this concept
of Separation there's me here and
there's you there and there's distance
in space and there's objects and there's
things in this three-dimensional reality
causes us to go from one point of
awareness I'm here to another point of
awareness uh say the front door and we
have to move through space and we move
through space it takes time right so
anything that we want in our lives takes
time and energy got to go to work
and you gotta you know you gotta do all
the things and then you got to save
money and then you go buy the thing and
that's the rules of three-dimensional
reality the plane of demonstration means
you got to do something right so then
there's me here and then my dreams are
way way out there and I estimate how
long it's going to take for me to arrive
at those streams because we're playing
by the rules of three-dimensional
reality and we play by those rules
um
for the most part I'm gonna wait for the
experience to occur in order to have the
experience producing emotion and the
emotion is the chemical feedback as a
result of the event now there's nothing
wrong with this that's the game in in
three-dimensional world
if you're going to shorten the distance
between cause and effect between the
thought of something and the experience
of something you got to go to a
different set of rules and you have to
create from the quantum field now the
quantum field is an invisible field of
energy that exists Beyond this space and
time now this takes a little bit of
imagination because
if we don't have any space between us
then we're connected there's no
separation uh and and there's no time so
now when you go to the realm of a
Quantum the rules change because in the
quantum things are connected energy
connects things together
so then if you were able to create from
the field instead of from matter and
it's not matter that's emitting a field
it's the field that's actually creating
matter if we could change information in
the field we could change the Hologram
in three-dimensional reality and it
turns out you only need two things to do
that
in a super coherent brain super
organized coherent brain and coherence
is a rhythm or an order so when the
brain is coherent it has a directive
it's an electrical charge it's the
signal we send out into the field we're
broadcasting information with our
thoughts now most people who have been
conditioned and hypnotized into the
rules of three-dimensional reality
they're waiting for the experience to
happen to feel the emotion of the
experience to take away their lack or
separation like whatever it's abundance
it's love it's healing whatever it is
but in the quantum model
you have to combine that clear intention
with an elevated emotion and that takes
heart coherence so we've done extensive
studies in training our community
to begin to feel the emotion of the
event before it happens and people say
well I don't know how it would feel
because I haven't experienced it well
the answer is really simple
if you felt gratitude or you felt
appreciation or a love for life or a joy
for existence
and you combine that clear intention
with an elevated emotion the heart
produces a magnetic field and that
magnetic field expands out and it
transcends the rules of space and time
when you feel whole when you feel this
elevated emotion you feel connected you
feel bonded and so when you feel the
emotion of your future
you're connecting to the energy of the
future and your body is so objective
it does not know the difference between
the real life experience that's creating
that emotion and the emotion that you're
creating by thought alone the body's
actually believing it's living in that
future reality in the present moment so
if the thought sends the signal out and
the feeling draws the event back and
your brain and heart coherence you got a
really powerful Wi-Fi signal and when
you begin to do this properly you no
longer have to go anywhere to get
anything in other words you're not
living by the rules of of cause and
effect you're living by the rules of
causing an effect you're producing an
outcome now here's the cool part if
there's a vibrational match between your
energy and you've really refined that
signal
and you can synchronize your energy you
start having synchronicities in your
life and you start getting Universal
science coming to you you have
opportunities you have synchronicities
serendipities coincidences and you're
not going anywhere to get it they're
coming to you now think about this if
you're connected to an invisible field
of energy that's the source of
everything physical and material if you
were Connected To Source why would you
go anywhere you wouldn't do that you
would say come to me right so so by
doing this properly
and causing an effect when you see
feedback in your life as the result of
what you're doing
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
now the cool part is is that once you
feel the excitement the inspiration The
Joy The Love For Life
that's actually reinforcing the feeling
that you've created with and if you
create again you refine the signal a bit
more you get more synchronicities no
more opportunities and the cool part
about our community
is that they're not saying oh God I have
to go create my life they're not saying
that they actually don't want to stop
doing it because they don't want those
they don't want the magic to end they
don't want those cool Quantum events
that are occurring in their life to stop
so it's not like I have to they're just
they're changing their energy and when
you change your energy you change your
life and I've been at this long enough
to tell you that nobody changes until
they change their energy and and and so
when you experiment with this as a as a
process and you learn a particular
formula and we've been we've been
refining this and studying it so much in
the last couple years
that the amount of coherence that we see
in some of our student Community is so
incredibly organized and not only
organized but the amount of energy in
the brain the amount of energy in the
heart is higher amplitude so no bigger
signal bigger Wi-Fi signal more
connection and so then you if you can
shorten the distance
between cause and effect
between the thought of what you want and
the experience of what you want
then you would start to master your life
and then you would start to see wow I
could actually if I if I could do this
what could I do next and and I'm happy
to say that the people are doing it
pretty well
so your brain is organized to reflect
everything you know in your life
your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact
of all the things you've learned and
experienced to this moment
so if you wake up every morning
and get out of bed on the same side
shut the alarm clock off with the same
finger
Shuffle into the bathroom and use the
toilet like you always do
go and get a cup of coffee and drink
coffee out of your favorite mug
then get in the shower and wash yourself
off in the same routine way
drive to work
get to work see the same people
that push the same emotional buttons
do the same things that you've memorized
and do so well
then hurry up and go home
and hurry up and check your emails and
hurry up and check your Facebook and
then watch your favorite television show
then hurry up and go to bed
here's my question
did your brain change at all that day
we could say that you were thinking the
same thoughts performing the same
unconscious actions living by the same
emotions but secretly expecting your
life to change
so there's a principle in neuroscience
and the principle says nerve cells that
fire together wire together
so if you're thinking the same thoughts
making the same choices demonstrating
the same behaviors
reproducing the same experiences that
stamp the same networks of neurons into
the same patterns
and then produce the same emotions
you're going to hardwire your brain
into a very finite signature
because as you fire and wire the same
circuits in the same way those circuits
begin to become more connected
and by the time you're 35 years old this
is science now
we become a set of memorized behaviors
unconscious habits automatic emotional
reactions beliefs and perceptions and
even attitudes that function just like a
computer program
and if you do something over and over
and over again the repetition of those
actions over time conditions your body
to know how to do it well better than
your mind
and a habit is when your body knows
better than your mind where you've done
something so many times that the body
now knows how to do it better than the
brain
and so 95 of most people's behaviors
attitudes thoughts beliefs emotional
reactions or subconscious programs
so why is that important
because you're here this week
to learn new information
and every time you learn something new
you make new Connections in your brain
that's what learning is learning is
forging new synaptic connections
physical evidence
as a result of your interaction in the
environment
and the footprints of Consciousness is
called learning making new connections
and the Nobel Prize Laureate candel in
the year 2000
found that when people learned one bit
of information
they doubled the number of Connections
in their brain from thirteen hundred
connections to 2600 connections
but if they didn't review that
information if they couldn't repeat it
if they couldn't remember it those
circuits pruned the part in hours or
days
so if learning is making new synaptic
connections then remembering is
maintaining and sustaining those
connections
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Alex hermosi
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there one has a
compounding View and perspective on time
and value and the other is short-sighted
and I can tell you the difference
between the people who are millionaires
that I'm friends with and people who are
billionaires that I'm friends with this
is probably one of the most fundamental
differences and so I was talking to